[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
et
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bonsoir ségolène royal ce
soir nicolas sarkozy bonsoir alors vous
êtes évidemment très nombreux nous
l'imaginons ce soir pour suivre ce débat
en france mais aussi à l'étranger
puisqu'il est diffusé en direct par de
nombreuses chaînes en europe mais aussi
dans le monde entier ce face à face est
attendu il n'y en a pas eu depuis 1995
depuis 12 ans en france et les français
vous ont donc choisi ségolène royal et
nicolas sarkozy pour ce second tour de
l'élection présidentielle alors
évidemment nous sommes là avec patrick
poivre d'arvor pour faire en sorte que
ce débat c'est déroule dans la plus
grande clarté et bien sûr les règles
seront les mêmes pour tout le monde
c'est à dire même temps de parole même
question les répond je le suppose sont
différentes avec arlette chabot nous
avons décidé de compte définir quatre
grands chapitres de durer à peu près
égale la conception du pouvoir et les
institutions les problèmes économiques
et sociaux les problèmes dits de
sociétés type éducation aux familles
recherche culture environnement et puis
des relations internationales avec
l'europe comprise bien entendu le tirage
au sort qui a été effectué tout à
l'heure au sein du csa va permettre à
nicolas sarkozy de commencer l'exercice
et à ségolène royal de le conclure mais
apparemment juste un petit mot comptine
détend l'atmosphère sur votre état
d'esprit aux uns et aux autres
ségolène royal vous vous sentez comment
très bien prêtre est ici très heureuse
merci nicolas sarkozy il est concentré
parce que c'est naturellement un débat
c'est quelque chose d'exigeant et des
français nous ont sélectionné madame
royal et moi pour être au 2e tour donc
nous portons tous les deux une
responsabilité là même celle de redonner
à la vie politique sa dignité et donc
que ce qui nous regarde quelles que
soient leurs convictions quel qu'ait été
leur choix au premier tour j'espère qu'à
la fin du les balles pourront se dire
voilà on en sait un peu plus on a
compris ce que l'un et l'autre nous
voulons faire pour la france alors tout
de suite le premier grand thème arlette
chabot voilà la première question elle
est simple c'est qu'elle une présidente
qu'elle préside en sueur et vous si vous
êtes élu vous appartenez tous les deux à
une nouvelle génération ensuite il ya eu
le quinquennat qui accélère un peu la
vie politique française donc quel style
voulez vous donner à cette présidence et
puis aussi quel pouvoir selon vous doit
d'avoir un président dans un monde
moderne et qu'elle contre-pouvoir pouvez
vous installer nicolas sarkozy pour une
première question c'est tout un panel
des questions d'abord la sphère de
génération je crois qu'il faut rester
calme là dessus sauf des quinquagénaires
dont l'entreprise parie tout jeune et je
ne pense pas d'ailleurs que la change
quelque chose à faire je crois que ce
qui est important c'est tirer des
conséquences de véritables ce une amie
politiques de ces dernières années en
france 2002 jean marie le pen au
deuxième tour
2005 le non au référendum on peut plus
faire la politique comme avant comme moi
j'essaierai si les français me font
confiance d'être impressionnant
république qui d'abord s'engagera sur
des résultats je veux des résultats il
s'agit plus de dire il s'agit plus de
proclamer des droits virtuel il faut
promettre aux français des droits qui
deviendront réel des résultats je
voudrais être un président de la
république qui pensaient responsabilités
je m'abrite serait pas derrière des
tabous derrière des excuses ou des
paravents je vais m'engager sur un
certain nombre de sujets je prendrai des
engagements je tiendrai parole et je
demanderai à être jugé là dessus je dois
également être un président un public
qui parlera beaucoup plus fréquemment
aux français qui leur expliquera les
choses
je demanderai d'ailleurs à chacun des
ministres je leur donnerai une lettre de
mission et chaque année ils rendront
compte de ce qu'ils ont fait ou pas pu
faire et pourquoi je voudrais également
de république irréprochable qu'est ce
que ça veut dire ça veut dire une
république où les nominations seront
simplement le fait de la compétence et
non pas de la connivence je vais
proposer donc un changement très
important qui ne s'est jamais produit
dans la république française que toutes
les grandes domination qui sont
aujourd'hui d'un pouvoir du président de
la république eh bien je proposerai que
le choix que je proposerai au conseil
des ministres soient ratifiés par un
vote à la majorité qualifiée des
commissions compétentes du parlement ce
qui veut dire que l'opposition aura son
droit de veto les nominations me
semble-t-il doivent être hors de tout
soupçon seule la compétence doit compter
et enfin je voudrais être un président
de la république qui fera une chose
nouvelle qui limitera le nombre de
mandats successifs
je pense qu'on ne peut pas être candidat
et président de la république plus de
deux mandats successifs pourquoi parce
que l'énergie que l'on met à dure et on
la met pas à faire moi la façon dont la
passion de ma ville porte un nom c'est
l'action je veux faire et si les
français nous choisissent que ce soit 1
à bréhal au moins ils nous choisirons
pour faire pour agir pour changer pour
obtenir des résultats c'est cela la
vision que j'ai du président là leak
moderne ségolène royal votre conception
de du pouvoir et de la présidence de
république si vous avez lu je souhaite
sortir la france de la situation dans
laquelle elle se trouve aujourd'hui
d'abord la dette puisque aujourd'hui la
france est endettée plus de 20000 euros
par français le nombre de travailleurs
pauvres deux millions et demi de
travailleurs pauvres en france de la
précarité qui s'est accrue du pouvoir
d'achat qui s'est abaissée de la
pauvreté deux millions et demi de
français vivent en dessous du seuil de
pauvreté parmi eux deux millions
d'enfants comme le dit l'association
emmaüs des retraites qui ont perdu du
pouvoir d'achat le niveau moyen des
retraites des femmes est de 850 euros
pour une carrière complète et de 622
euros pour une carrière incomplète parce
que les femmes subissent très durement
le chômage partiel un déficit de la
sécurité sociale qui s'élève à 11
milliards d'euros un chômage qui touche
près de 3 millions de personnes
des agressions qui ont augmenté depuis
2002 de plus 30% de violences physiques
gratuites contre les personnes en 2002
vous aviez dit monsieur sarkozy vous
aviez parlé de la tôle et de la
tolérance zéro et vous avez vu
qu'aujourd'hui les français s'inquiètent
beaucoup de la montée et des violences
et d agressivité dans la société
française le nombre de faits de violence
à l'école a augmenté de 26% alors voilà
je veux être la présidente de la
république qui va faire une france où
l'agressivité les violences recul qui va
faire une france qui va gagner la
bataille contre le chômage et contre la
vie chère qui va permettre aussi que
recul les inégalités parce que je crois
que toutes ses formes d'insécurité au
quotidien d'insécurité sociale appelle
de nouvelles règles du jeu appelle à
nouveau système politique appelle en
effet des responsables politiques plus
efficaces qu'ils ne l'ont été au cours
des cinq dernières années et même au
delà sans doute parce que je ne sais
mathis pas l'histoire mais il est vrai
aussi que quand vous l'avez dit je crois
que la morale politique puisque vous
venez d'évoquer ce mot demande aussi que
les responsables politiques rendent des
comptes par rapport à ce qu'ils ont fait
je sais aussi que ce qui intéresse les
français c'est le futur mais malgré tout
monsieur nicolas sarkozy vous rendez
vous estimez vous une partie pour une
part responsable de la situation dans
laquelle se trouve la france aujourd'hui
au plus qu'une question me poser je
crois que là le moindre des courtoisies
c'est d'y répondre et ce que je suis
responsable d'une partie du bilan du
gouvernement wimad moyens vous avez
parlé des violences je suis responsable
j'ai été ministre de l'intérieur pendant
4 j'ai trouvé une situation qui était
catastrophique qui d'ailleurs a compté
pour beaucoup madame royal dans la
défaite de vos amis du gouvernement
auquel vous appartenez à l'époque si en
2002 les français ont changé non même
pas qualifié le premier ministre que
vous souteniez pour le deuxième tour il
y avait bien une raison cette raison
chacun à observer c'est parce que les
violences et la délinquance avait
explosé et c'est dans ces conditions que
j'ai été nommé ministre de l'intérieur
au tout n'a pas été réussi et un bon je
voudrais vous d'ailleurs vous dire que
je suis d'accord c'est que sur les
défaillances de la république gauche et
droite confondues nous avons chacun
notre part et vous avez raison de dire
qu'il faut pas avoir une vision
manichéenne donc sur le bilan en matière
de violence en matière de délinquance
avec le même appareil statistique mais
le moyen le même rien n'a changé c'est
le même à l'époque de daniel vaillant
c'est le même maintenant sur les 50
gouvernement jospin la violence la
délinquance avait augmenté de 18% sur
les cinq années du gouvernement d'une
comète quinquennat de jacques chirac la
délinquance avec le même appareil
statistique a diminué de 10% je dis pas
tout est résolu ça fait quand même 1
million de victimes en moins c'est me
semble-t-il suffisant pour que je ne
parte pas en courant lorsqu'on évoque le
mot bilan sur la sécurité il ya deuxième
point où on est en accord c'est qu'il
faut résoudre le problème de la dette
vous avez parfaitement raison mais
madame royal vous savez bien vous
connaissez les chiffres comme bois
j'imagine que dans cette campagne
électorale en est au même niveau de
préparation
ça fait depuis combien de temps que les
budgets de la france sont en déficit 25
ans
on peut pas expliquer que l'endettement
de la france dépend de ces cinq
dernières années vous avez raison il
faut réduire l'endettement de la france
le problème c'est comment on le fait je
propose une chose
45% du budget de la france c'est le
salaire de la fonction publique et les
pensions de retraite 45 % 15 % c'est les
intérêts de la dette 60% ces deux postes
donc se trouvera à poser pour madame
royal comme pour moi c'est pas une
question de gauche ou de droite c'est
une question de bon sens si vous voulez
comme je le pense et comme moi réduire
la dette de la france va bien falloir
faire des économies on va pas réduire la
dette de la france si on n'est pas son
temps nous avons une opportunité
historique la pyramide d'âge dans la
fonction publique il faut réduire le
train de vie de l'état réduire les
dépenses il y aura donc si je suis
président de la république je veux
proposer aux fonctionnaires un pacte de
progrès on remplacera un départ sur deux
à la retraite
la moitié des gains de productivité
permettant d'augmenter les salaires des
fonctionnaires parce que les salaires de
la fonction publique sont très bas et
l'autre moitié des gains de productivité
permettra de réduire la dette de la
france cet impératif est ce que au moins
sur ce choix là nous ne pourrions pas
gauche et droite opposition et majorité
selon le choix des français nous trouver
d'accord pour dire pas bien sûr si on
veut soulager la dette des français qui
est injuste pour les générations qui
viennent va bien falloir qu'on fasse des
économies
les grosses économies ont l'effet sur
les gros postes de dépenses ségolène
royal vous avez revenir un instant sur
la conception du pouvoir parce que je
crois que c'est important sur 7 cet
engagement qui consiste à tout chef
d'état demain de rendre des comptes sur
son pouvoir passer nous sommes en 2007
nous ne sommes pas en 2002 et dont
j'observe déjà que sur le bilan que j'ai
fait tout à l'heure sur la situation de
la france qui inquiète aujourd'hui les
français vous ne contestez pas ce bilan
j'ajoute monsieur nicolas sarkozy qu'il
y a deux jours une femme policière s'est
fait violer tout près de bobigny tout
près de son commissariat en sortant de
son commissariat et au mois de mars
dernier au même endroit l'une de ses
collègues s'étaient également fait
violer qu'est ce qui s'est passé entre
ces deux faits
pour qu'aucune protection ne soit
apportée à une femme policière et bien
je le dis demain si je suis élue
présidente de la république
les agents publics seront protégés et en
particulier les femmes elles seront
raccompagnés à leur domicile
lorsqu'elles sortent tardivement des
commissariats de police et je dis cela
parce que ça me permet de venir
directement à la question que vous posez
sur les agents en public et sur la
diminution du nombre de fonctionnaires
non monsieur que sarkozy je ne
diminuerait pas le nombre de
fonctionnaires ou alors il va falloir me
dire dans quel domaine vous allez
réduire ce nombre de fonctionnaires
parce que s'il y avait davantage de
policiers peut-être que cette femme
n'aurait pas été violé parce qu'elle
n'aurait pas été seul elle serait
rentrée chez elle avec un collègue
peut-être que s'il y avait davantage de
fonctionnaires aussi si vous n'aviez pas
supprimer autant d'emplois dans
l'éducation nationale
nous n'aurions pas les fermetures de
classes à la rentrée prochaine et une
augmentation de l'échec scolaire
peut-être que si nous avions aussi
davantage d'agents publics et notamment
d'infirmières nous n'aurions pas une
dégradation de leurs conditions de
travail à l'hôpital public et une montée
des inquiétudes comme je lai encore
observé récemment en me rendant dans un
hôpital public à la corbeille ou les
personnels de l'hôpital ont tiré la
sonnette d'alarmé et sont très inquiet
sur l'avenir de l'hôpital public et ils
m'ont demandé de les aider et je leur ai
donné les engagements sur ce sujet oui
l'hôpital public redeviendra une
priorité alors bien sûr on peut faire
améliorer l'efficacité du service public
on peut évaluer l'efficacité du service
public mais il faut dire très clairement
aux français lorsque vous leur dites
qu'il y aura 2 125 mille fonctionnaires
en moins où vous aller les retirer moi
je crois tout le contraire de ce que
vous venez de dire c'est à dire que ce
sont des services publics efficaces qui
garantissent aussi la compétitivité
économique d'une entreprise et la
compétitivité économique de l'économie
française et lorsque l'on demande aux
investisseurs étrangers pourquoi ils
viennent en france avez-vous ce qu'ils
citent en premier il cite la qualité du
service public de la france alors le
nombre de fonctionnaires sera maintenu
en revanche
comme je réformerai la décentralisation
c'est à dire comme je vais faire une
nouvelle étape mais une vraie cette fois
de régionalisation au lieu d'avoir des
doublons des chevauchements de
l'augmentation de la fiscalité locale
parce qu'avec votre loi l'état a
transféré des compétences sans
transférer les ressources et sans
clarifier la reste la répartition des
responsabilités
ce que je propose c'est de lutter contre
toutes les formes de gaspillage d'argent
public parce que chacun sera au clair
sur ses responsabilités la région sera
ce qu'elle a à faire et en particulier
les aides économiques les départements
seront claires sur leur responsabilité
les communautés d'agglomération et les
communautés de communes aussi et les
communes et il n'y aura plus ces
chevauchements et ses gaspillages c'est
à dire une véritable réforme de l'état
pour qu'il soit à la fois plus rapide
plus efficace et plus économe en fonds
publics alors je précise que
pratiquement la seconde près vous devez
égalité de temps de parole je vous
laisse répondre nicolas sarkozy et puis
ensuite on ira peut-être au fond de
notre première question à savoir est-ce
qu'il faut changer les institutions
actuelles
je veux pas polémiquer avec madame watch
jurés juge juste un mot elle trouve qu'à
passer de policiers c'est dommage que le
groupe socialiste n'est pas voter les
créations d'emplois de policiers sur les
quatre dernières années c'est dommage
parce que permettez vous ne seriez vous
interrompez assuré le commissariat de
clichy que vous aviez promis il n'est
toujours pas ouvert madame alors en
effet et sur le manque de policiers
madame très bien mais alors expliquez
nous pourquoi le groupe socialiste n'a
pas voté les créations de la loi de
programmation 2002 parce que ça n'était
pas suffisant sans doute et qu'en
particulier avec en particulier il n'y
avait pas suffisamment déquilibre aussi
avec la justice car la justice aussi est
en situation de grande misère vous
consolez vous nous dire que vous allez
aussi parmi les fonctionnaires supprimés
des magistrats jeu alors qu'il n'ya
aucune réponse pour le fond il n'y a
aucune réponse sur l'accueil des mineurs
délinquants et que vous n avez rien
compris les centres et renforce cible
comme attendu à ce niveau si vous le
permettez donc sur la réduction de
l'endettement aucune piste d'économie
s'agit simplement pour madame royal de
dire qu'elle va transférer aux régions
ce qui est d'ailleurs assez cohérent ce
qui permettra aux régions de faire une
autre augmentation d'impôts après les
augmentations faramineuses que vous avez
réalisé les deux dernières années sur
les policiers il y en a pas assez mais
chaque fois que j'ai proposé des
créations de postes puisque nous en
avons créé beaucoup
des milliers de policiers et de
gendarmes le groupe socialiste les a pas
voté mais ils ont pas sans ce n'est pas
le plus important alors ce qui est très
important si vous avez parlé de cette
abominable viol deux dans le parc de
bobines et dites moi si vous devez faire
accompagner toutes les femmes
fonctionnaires chez elle la nuit oui la
nuit eh bien eh bien il faudra dire il y
aura une fonction publique au service
des français et puis une autre fonction
publique au service des fonctionnaires
qui rentrent et moi c'est dans
l'association amusnaw il abuse pas ce
crime abominable mettez vous avez nommé
0 est-ce que vous permettez de répondre
simplement bon la claque la solution
c'est pas mettre un garde du corps à
chaque fonctionnaire femme qui angel la
solution c'est de réprimer les
délinquants pour qu'il y en ait plus
aucun témoin alors qu'est ce que je
propose d'abord je propose qu'il n'y ait
plus un seul délinquants sexuels et vous
savez parfaitement madame royal s'est
érodée al s'agissant ravier dit en 2002
s'agissant mais non madame s'agissant
web où nous ne vous abaissez pas se
nourrir tolérance zéro vous avez dit
gilles à vos déclarations d'un mais ce
qu est ce qu ont décidé ce que vous
souffrez que je puisse faire une phrase
me faisant mal alors sur les délinquants
sexuels je propose que n'a plus un seul
qui puisse sortir de prison
car vous connaissez la récidive sans
s'engager à suivre un traitement premier
point deuxième point sans pointer en
étant obligé de pointer au commissariat
la gendarmerie de son domicile toutes
les semaines en matière de viol les
récits dit sont considérables deuxième
proposition jo fait s'agissant des
récits davis car vous savez sans doute
que 50% des crimes et des délits sont le
fait de 5% de délinquant
multirécidiviste
je propose d'instaurer des peines
planchers jeté aux français si je suis
président de la république avant la fin
de l'été 2007 les récidivistes seront
punis très sévèrement et ils seront au
moment de la récidive de la certitude
d'une sanction sévère on ne peut plus
continuer à voir des individus qui
viennent 50 60 70 fois devant le même
tribunal troisième élément il faut
résoudre le problème des mineurs
l'impunité des mineurs est
catastrophique il faut réformer
l'ordonnancé pénale de 45 et si je suis
élu président de la république je
proposerai qu'un mineur multirécidiviste
entre 16 et 18 ans soient punis comme un
majeur par parenthèse madame lorsqu'on
est une victime qu'on est victime d'un
individu 17 ans qu'on est victime d'un
individu 19 ans le résultat est le même
on m'avait interrogé sur le fait de
savoir où est ce qu'on trouve les
économies de fonctionnaires
naturellement bon avec ce que je propose
madame nous reviendrons aux effectifs de
la fonction publique en 1992 époque où
françois mitterrand était président de
la république je ne sache pas qu'à
l'époque la france était sous
administrée la france à créer un million
d'emplois publics depuis 1981 et vous
venez nous explique t on peut rien
changer alors prenons des exemples
20000 douaniers
ça n'a pas bougé depuis 1980 entre temps
la supprimer les frontières
l'état a transféré la compétence de la
formation professionnelle aux régions
donnez-vous bien monsieur prévost
d'abord entre temps les effectifs de la
formation professionnelle dans l'état
ont augmenté de 60%
l'état a transféré aux départements les
compétences sociales tenez vous bien
entre temps les effectifs de l'état sur
les compétences sociales ont été
multiplié par quatre l'informatisation a
fait des progrès considérables notamment
dans un ministère que ce côté puisque je
les diriger le ministère des finances
il y à 80 mille fonctionnaires à la dgi
pour calculer l'impôt soixante mille
fonctionnaires à la comptabilité
publique pour le percevoir tout le monde
sait qu'il faut faire la fusion des deux
pour obtenir des économies de postes qui
peut considérer que sur cinq millions de
fonctionnaires toute fonction publique
considérée il n'y a pas matière à
améliorer la productivité alors un
dernier point parce que c'est un point
d'accord c'est sur l'hôpital bien sûr
qu'un malaise de l'hôpital il ya un
million de fonctionnaires
dans l'hôpital c'est un lieu de toutes
les douleurs de tous les malheurs et en
même temps tous les bonheurs ce
personnel hospitalier faut y penser il
faut le soutenir mais madame qu'est-ce
qui a désorganisé l'hôpital sur les 35
heures ce sont les 35 heures qui ont mis
à bas l'hôpital public français c'est ça
la réalité des choses à l'hôpital il
faut des postes vous nous expliquerez
d'ailleurs comment vous augmenter les
recettes de l'assurance maladie je suis
prêt à en débattre au moment où il
évoquera mais c'est les 35 heures ont
été une catastrophe il faut bien le dire
généralisé pour l'économie française
mais qu'ils s'agit semble fidèle public
ont considérablement détruit son
organisation pour une raison simple
c'est que l'hôpital ça fonctionne le
jour la nuit sept jours sur sept et
naturellement 24 heures sur 24 heures
veillée les uns aux autres pendant trop
de temps d'avancé 4 minutes 42 de
différence entre nicolas sarkozy et
ségolène royal qui répond sûr sur
l'hôpital public est une question
cruciale et essentielle puisque c'est
aussi sur le maintien des petits
hôpitaux la présence de santé sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
comme vous venez de le dire très
justement en effet les 35 heures dont
d'ailleurs les infirmières les aides
soignantes et tous les personnels
hospitaliers se réjouissent parce qu'il
travaille de nuit est d'ailleurs lorsque
vous leur aviez proposé de travailler
plus pour gagner plus vous avez vu que
cette proposition n'a pas eu beaucoup de
succès dans l'hôpital et je j'ai
rencontré encore récemment les
infirmières et en effet ne souhaitent
pas travailler plus parce qu'elles
travaillent déjà dans des horaires et
dans des conditions extrêmement
difficiles alors oui il va falloir créer
des postes dans la fonction publique
hospitalière et ces postes ont été
insuffisants au moment des 35 heures
c'est bien la raison pour laquelle nous
ne pourrons pas diminuer le nombre de
fonctionnaires car si nous pouvons en
effet en diminuer au ministère des
finances et notamment dans les services
des douanes ça sera pour en créer là où
les besoins sont nécessaires pour
remettre du service public là où il n'y
en a plus pour remettre du service
public en milieu rural ou dans les
quartiers dans lesquels en effet le
manque de services publics explique le
délitement du lien républicain mais je
voudrais revenir sur les autres éléments
que vous avez ok sur la question de la
délinquance sexuelle qui vous en
conviendrez avec moi là rien de
génétique je crois qu'il faut aller plus
loin il faut aller plus loin et moins je
demande que les pédophiles en
particulier ne soient pas relâchés tant
que la commission spéciale qui doute qui
aurait dû être mis en place dans les
prisons n'a pas formellement dit par
expertise qu'ils sont désormais non
nocifs or aujourd'hui il y à des
délinquants sexuels qui sont relâchés
parce qu'ils n'ont pas eu les soins en
prison les soins que la loi pourtant
prévoit et donc je crois que l'urgence
dans ce domaine c'est que les soins
soient donnés dans la prison et c'est
qu'ensuite ces délinquants ne soit
relâché que lorsque l'arc perdre la
garantie qu'ils ne peuvent pas
recommencer est donné par le comité
d'experts qui doit siéger dans les
prisons sur les multirécidivistes vous
avez été quatre ans ministre de
l'intérieur pourquoi n'avez vous pas
fait cette loi elle est en effet
nécessaire mais je pense que ce qui est
plus urgent encore c'est la question de
la réponse au premier acte de
délinquance or aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de réponse vous le savez au premier acte
de délinquance pourquoi parce que les
magistrats n'ont pas de solution les
centres fermés n'ont pas été construits
et moi je ferais si je suis élu
président de la république parce que je
crois que la question de la lutte contre
toutes les formes de violence et de
délinquance et en particulier que le
fait d'éviter aux mineurs la prison doit
appeler à des solutions novatrices j'ai
parlé de l'encadrement militaire pour
les mineurs et je le mettre en place les
centres éducatifs renforcés seront
effectivement créé des peines adaptées
bien évidemment au premier délit seront
exécutés car on sait bien que s'il y a
une réponse au premier acte de
délinquance dans 70% des cas il n'y a
pas de récidive et s'il n'ya pas de
réponse au premier acte de délinquance
dans 70% des cas il y a récidive donc
tout est à repenser dans ce domaine et
en particulier ma priorité
sera sur la prévention et sur la
sanction au premier acte de délinquance
parce que je crois que c'est comme cela
que nous réussirons à freiner la montée
vers l'un délinquance de masse enfin
vous aviez parlé de la dette de la lutte
contre la dette moi je propose d'abord
de relancer la croissance c'est comme
cela que nous lutterons contre la dette
je pense que la france a la capacité de
réaliser un taux de croissance de 2 et
demi pour cent c'est la moyenne
nationale et je le ferai en faisant un
nouveau pacte avec les entreprises je
veux réconcilier la france avec les
entreprises et jeudi que la
compétitivité économique n'est pas
incompatible avec le progrès social bien
au contraire les trois piliers du
développement économique demain seront
la compétitivité des pme celles qui
n'ont pas qui ne dépendent pas des fonds
de pension et c'est sur elle que je
concentrerai les 63 milliards d'euros de
dette publique qui aujourd'hui sont
distribuées de façon uniforme à toutes
les entreprises une entreprise du cac40
reçoit autant d'allègements de charges
qu'une pme qui se bat tous les jours
pour conquérir des marchés et des
emplois et bien moi je ferai cette
réforme et je vais concentrer sur les
pme les aides publiques c'est sur elle
que je vais faire les allègements de
charges c'est pour elle que je vais
relancer l'investissement et dans
l'innovation et dans la recherche etc
pourrait aussi que je baisserais l'impôt
sur les bénéfices des sociétés pour tous
les bénéfices qui sont réinvestis dans
l'entreprise l'impôt sur les sociétés
sera divisé par deux sur ces pme le
deuxième axe de la relance de la
croissance c'est la qualité du dialogue
social et on sait que tous les pays du
nord de l'europe qui ont réussi à
relancer la croissance sont les pays qui
ont mis en place un dialogue social de
qualité qui permet aux syndicats de
faire des compromis sociaux et
d'anticiper c'est à dire d'être informé
en amont des stratégies de l'entreprise
pour y contribuer pour y participer pour
faire les efforts de formation
professionnelle là où se trouve des
trésors de valeur ajoutée et enfin je
mettrai en mouvement le levier
écologique parce que je pense que c'est
dans cette filière du développement
écologique et des éco-industries que la
france à des emplois à conquérir sans
doute plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'emplois à conquérir dans ce domaine et
si la croissance est supérieure à deux
et demi pour cent à la fois je finance
mon pacte présidentiel
j'ai donc relancer la croissance en
mettant l'accent sur les pme et s'il ya
davantage de croissance je prends
l'engagement que tout ce qui sera au
dessus de 2 et demi pour cent de
croissance sera consacrée au
remboursement de la dette mais voilà
comme vous avez rééquilibrer votre temps
de parler et bien au delà je voudrais
qu'on revienne à la première question
que nous avions posé sur votre
conception de la présence d'un public et
peut-être sur les institutions ou est-ce
qu'il faut changer de république pour
cela le passé de la prostitution
c'est enfin le
mans voudra pas mais
a évoqué tous les sujets en même temps
le risque de les survoler pas être assez
précis en ce qu'attend donc laissez moi
la responsabilité de mépris je me suis
je vous le voulez j'ai un jeu permet pas
critiquer mais je fais simplement
maintenant c'est très cohérent parler de
tout en même temps on va pas pouvoir
approfondir le tenir par dom et où se
tient la dette et la relance économique
ça se tient ben mouaïa tu me permettait
la précision n'est pas inutile dans le
débat public pour que les français
comprennent ce qu'on veut faire alors il
me semble que s'agissant la réduction de
la dette vous n'avait fixé aucune piste
d'économie c'est votre droit le plus
absolu alors la relance de la croissance
est encore plus intéressant vous n'avait
donné aucun moyen pour relancer la
croissance j'en ai un parce que vous
avez raison il faut relancer la
croissance le problème de la france
c'est qu'à grosso modo 1 % de croissance
de moins que les grandes démocraties les
grandes économies qui progresse dans le
monde pourquoi pour une raison à ne rien
c'est parce qu'on travaille moins que
les autres quel est le levier pour
obtenir 1 % de croissance de plus c'est
respecter le travail récompensé le
travail considéré le travail valorisé le
travail il y a dix pays en europe qui
ont le plein emploi
10,5 vraiment très fort je pense au
danemark à la suède à l'irlande au
royaume uni dans une certaine façon
l'espagne ça devrait vous frappez madame
royal y en a pas un seul d'entre eux qui
a fait le partage du temps de travail il
y en a pas un seul d'entre eux qui a
fait 35 heures monsieur zapatero qui est
venu dans le meeting de toulouse que
vous avez tenu mardi à madrid que jamais
une frêle et 35 heures en espagne qui ne
voulait pas porter atteinte à la
compétitivité des entreprises vous dites
et ses sympathiques et c'est juste il
faut aider les pme françaises permettez
que je vous pose la question est ce que
vous allez comme c'est prévu dans le
programme socialiste généraliser les 35
heures à tout le monde notamment aux pme
ce que je souhaite moi c'est libérer la
possibilité de travailler en france par
quels moyens on va encourager les les
gens qui veulent travailler plus pour
gagner plus comment on va le faire tout
est fait aujourd'hui pour décourager le
l'obtention des heures supplémentaires
toute entreprise qui donnera des heures
supplémentaires ne paiera pas de charges
dessus tout salarié qui fera sur la base
du volontariat des heures
supplémentaires ne paiera pas d'impôt
dessus rendez vous compte que quand on
est au smic et qu'on travaille 50
minutes de plus par jour c'est 15%
d'augmentation de salaire ya un
formidable problèmes de pouvoir d'achat
en france le salaire n'est pas l'ennemi
de l'emploi et partant cet argent qu'on
va donner ce pouvoir d'achat qu'on va
distribuer va relancer la croissance mon
moyen pour relancer la croissance c'est
de libérer les forces de travail de deux
petites remarques si l'on permettez vous
me dites il faut créer des nouveaux
emplois dans la fonction publique ok
d'accord pourquoi pas c'est sympathique
nous payer comment est ce qu'on fait
comme l'a demandé françois hollande une
nouvelle csg et est ce que vous pouvez
dire aux français qui nous écoutent
aujourd'hui que si vous êtes élu il y
aura ou non une nouvelle cg parce que
c'est bien beau de dire aux gens on va
faire de nouvelles dépenses mais c'est
avec leur argent non pas si l argent des
français c'est l'argent qui taxent le
travail c'est l'argent qui fait en sorte
qu'ils attendent délocalisation pourquoi
parce que les impôts les charges sont si
lourdes
quelle tentation de la délocalisation il
faut protéger les français contre les
délocalisations
si vous augmentez les dépenses vous
serez obligés d'augmenter les impôts et
si vous augmentez les impôts vous
détruisez de l'emploi et vous détruisez
du pouvoir d'achat et vous détruisez de
la croissance c'est pas très intelligent
de dire ça mais c'est ce qu'on fait tous
les pays qui ont le plein emploi moi je
me suis engagé sur le plan points je dis
aux français au bout de cinq ans on sera
à 5% il n'y a aucune raison que ce que
les autres ont réussi enrichissent pas
nous mêmes mais les autres qu'est ce
qu'ils ont fait ils ont libéré les
forces de travail ils n'ont pas fait les
35 heures vous dites on pète rose
entreprises mais ce que vous dites aux
français que les 35 heures ça coûte 10 7
milliards d'euros chaque année pour
empêcher les angles travail et je
mettrai un terme aux préretraites 5
milliards d'euros chaque année pour que
des quinquagénaires plainte jeunesse
peut-être comme nous soient obligés de
partir en retraite alors qu'ils veulent
continuer à travailler voilà comment on
libère le pays voilà comment on obtient
la croissance et voilà comment on sera
au plein emploi
d'abord je n'ai pas dit que j'en
vendrais le nombre de fonctionnaires
donc ne déformez pas c'est ce que j'ai
cru nantes pour fonction publique j'ai
dit que je rachetais d'ailleurs j'ai dit
que je maintenais leur nombre mais que
je redéployaient le nombre de
fonctionnaires en les retirant là où il
n'était plus nécessaire puisque vous
proposer dans medal infernal parce que
je suis d'accord il pouvait pas passer
d'une fonction publique et notre donc
dans le faux mouvement au moment du
départ à la retraite au lieu de recruter
des douaniers j'aurais parlé des
infirmières et non c'est pas possible
maintenant mais je suis vraiment ce
n'est pas parce que la fonction publique
hospitalière s'est payé par un autre
budget que le budget de l'état ou tel a
plaisanté autonome vous plaisantez vous
plaisantez enfin tous les fonds publics
tout se tient nancy font plus le plein
parce que vous pensez à retirer vous
agirez l'assurance maladie non c'est pas
moi qui gère l'assurance maladie mais
c'est comme de l'argent public est
dépensé des cotisations qui sont payés
sur les salaires donc alors nous pouvons
par des fouilles entre les collectivités
territoriales et l'état vous pouvez pas
redéployer entre les pins 6 janvier
l'assurance maladie si vous voulez vous
accéder aux responsabilités et bien moi
je le pourrai a bon jeu le betting mais
si je suis dans la république je
pourrais pas diminuer les effectifs du
conseil régional de poitou charentes et
pourquoi pas ah bon parce que sa semelle
l'indépendance des collectivités
territoriales parce que vous aimeriez
droit de libre arbitre ils ont agrandi
par la constitution ce n'est pas l'état
qui le décidera c'est la cohérence
politique de la répartition des
responsabilités car aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous avez fait
loin ceux de la décentralisation
tellement confuse qui l'y a gelé dit
tout à l'heure donc je ne veux pas
m'étendre qui a entraîné une
superposition des compétences entre les
différentes collectivités territoriales
ce qui fait que tout le monde s'occupe
de tout et qu'il ya donc beaucoup trop
de gaspillage et bien moi je remettrai
de là arte dans les responsabilités et
donc la fonction publique sera mieux
réparti entre la fonction publique de
l'état la fonction publique hospitalière
et les fonctions publiques territoriale
voilà comment j'entends à la fois
remettre de l'ordre juste dans
l'administration et lutter contre toutes
les formes de gaspillage alors
maintenant venons en au sujet central
qui est en effet la question du travail
vous avez fait une proposition elle a le
mérite d'exister sur la question des
heures supplémentaires
moi je crois que votre proposition est
non seulement dangereuses et inefficaces
pourquoi et pourtant je fais le même
constat que vous je crois qu'on ne
travaille pas suffisamment en france on
ne travaille pas suffisamment parce
qu'il ya trop de personnes au chômage
alors si vous des exonérations des
heures supplémentaires qu'est ce qui va
se passer un employeur aura davantage
intérêt à donner des heures
supplémentaires à un salarié car
recruter un nouveau salarié or nous
sommes le pays qui subit à la fois le
taux de chômage des jeunes le plus élevé
et le taux de chômage des seniors le
plus élevé par ailleurs les heures
supplémentaires sont possibles
aujourd'hui vous le savez bien il ya eu
deux lois fillion qui ont libéré deux
cent vingt heures supplémentaires par an
et que se passe-t-il dans les
entreprises cette possibilité là n'est
même pas utilisés par les salariés les
salariés n'utilisent en moyenne que 120
heures supplémentaires par an pourquoi
parce qu'ils ne veulent pas forcément
travailler plus ou parce que
l'entreprise n'a pas suffisamment de
plans charge pour faire des heures
supplémentaires moi je propose au
contraire de donner de l'emploi à ceux
qui n'en n'ont pas et c'est comme cela
que nous ferons aussi revenir des
cotisations et je propose de donner de
l'emploi aux jeunes qui n'en n'ont pas
car ce qui ronge aujourd'hui l'équilibré
la société française ce sont les jeunes
diplômés et qualifiés qui n'ont pas
accès à l'entreprise pourquoi parce que
l'entreprise demande à la fois de
l'expérience professionnelle aux jeunes
mais en même temps ne fait pas confiance
à ses jeunes et les inégalités se sont
creusées entre les jeunes qui ont des
relations et y trouve à entrer dans les
entreprises à faire leurs preuves et
très souvent ils font leurs preuves
parce que nous avons un très bon système
de formation et ceux qui n'ont pas ces
relations et qui n'arrivent pas à entrer
dans l'entreprise et c'est pourquoi je
propose de créer sur les cinq années les
cinq cent mille emplois tremplin pour
les jeunes et que mon objectif c'est de
faire en sorte qu'en france les jeunes
ne restent pas pendant plus de six mois
au chômage ou en recherche d'activité
ces emplois tremplins ça marche parce
que moi je suis responsable politique
qui veut faire des choses qui marchent
alors que votre décision d'exonérer les
heures supplémentaires ça coûte 5
milliards d'euros alors que les emplois
tremplins ça marche et ça ne coûte rien
pourquoi ça ne coûte rien parce que
c'est le recyclage des fonds de la
formation professionnelle
et des dépenses d'indemnisation du
chômage et je préfère voir un jeune en
activité payer pendant six mois par les
collectivités locales qui ont déjà
commencé ça fonctionne dans ma propre
région j'ai déjà créer 3000 emplois
tremplins et ensuite les jeunes font
leurs preuves dans l'entreprise il
montre de quoi ils sont capables
et au bout de ces six mois l'entreprise
leur fait un contrat à durée
indéterminée et s'ils sont inadaptées à
l'entreprise à ce moment là on leur
donne une formation professionnelle
complémentaire autrement dit je pense
que l'emploi va à l'emploi et qu'un
jeune qualifiés diplômés team a la
possibilité de montrer ce dont il est
capable dans l'entreprise bien souvent
il va rester dans l'entreprise parce
qu'il va y avoir un lien de confiance
voilà doit y aller nicolas sarkozy
joëlle je te faire un petit rappel
historique depuis 1974 c'était le
lendemain du premier choc pétrolier et
c'était justement le premier camp débat
entre deux candidats à la finale de la
présidentielle
tous les candidats de gauche et de
droite nous ont dit je vais gagner la
bataille contre l'emploi et on voit où
on en est aujourd'hui qu'elle quelles
sont vos solutions avoue nicolas sarkozy
pour arriver au plein emploi soit
d'abord aujourd'hui c'est le plus faible
taux de chômage en france depuis 25 ans
je dis pas qu'on a tout réussi mais
c'est le taux plus faibles alors comment
on peut faire pour aller plus loin
et c'est une différence kelly madame
royal est très intéressant c'est une
différence essentielle entre son projet
et le mien au fond elle est dans la
stricte logique socialiste du partage du
temps de travail il ya un temps de
travail qui est comme un gâteau on doit
se le partager et elle nous dit que
personne ne travaille plus que 35 heures
comme ça ça obligera les entreprises
engagées d'autres personnes
nulle nulle part ailleurs dans le monde
on ne fait ça y'a pas un pays pas un
seul madame socialiste ou pas qui a
retenu la logique du partage du temps de
travail qui est une erreur monumentale
les 35 heures n'ont pas créé d'emploi et
les 35 heures ont été responsables
d'autre chose de plus grave encore c'est
la rigueur salariale qui fait que nos
salaires sont trop bas ça pèse sur le
pouvoir d'achat des français et le
pouvoir d'achat en berne c'est moins de
croissance qu'est ce que je propose une
autre stratégie la stratégie qui a
marché partout vous citez souvent les
démocraties du nord de l'europe c'est ce
qu'ils font vous avez votre ami blair
au royaume uni c'est ce qu'il a fait
monsieur zapatero c'est ce qu'il a fait
le travail des uns créé le travail des
autres c'est pourquoi l'institut
rexecode organise parfaitement
indépendant à noter nos projets
économiques qu'est ce qu'il a dit mais
on connaît la musique celle en fait
c'est l'organisme du medef ah bon mais
si j'avais bien il vous savez par qui
les dirigeait c'est l'organisme du medef
c'est faux vous savez pas qui c'est fou
vous savez par qui il est dirigé par
monsieur michel disdier qui est il l'un
des économistes que monsieur jospin
avait nommé lui-même en 98 dans son
conseil des experts lors plus
l'organisent coglais de contester son
président a été nommé par lionel jospin
lui même dans le conseil des experts qui
entourait le premier ministre d'alors
oui c'est pas gentil pour monsieur j'ose
pas qu'est ce qu'il a dit l'institut
rexecode que votre projet entraîné par
an et demi de croissance en moins c'est
si oui voilà c'est ça c'est bien
l'organisme du medef monsieur juppé nous
a servi cet argument régulièrement
saisis continué cantine merci de
merci d'autoriser et que mon projet créé
230 ni emploi de plus voilà quelques
medef mais non pourquoi pour finaliser
alésienne j'avais alesi continuer
pourquoi toute personne qui n'a pas
votre opinion vous le regardez avec
ironie voir avec mépris j'ai d'abord
l'institut rexecode n'est pas l'institut
du medef mais quand bien même et est ce
qu'au nom de quoi parce qu'on est chef
d'entreprise je n'y connais rien à
l'emploi parce qu'on n'est pas de gauche
on n'a pas le droit de parler de ces
sujets je j'attache beaucoup de prix à
vous à vos avait invoqué sa vos réponses
je ne dis pas que c'est stupide j'essaie
de comprendre et d'expliquer aux
français quelles que soient nos
différences tous les pays du monde ont
augmenté les possibilités de travailler
alors première maudite modifications
aujourd'hui les heures supplémentaires
dans les entreprises de moins de 20
salariés s'est payé 10 % de plus je
ferai payer 25 % de plus pourquoi parce
que comme dira pas de charge les
entreprises pour augmenter les salaires
avec des salaires augmentent et on donne
du pouvoir d'achat avec du pouvoir
d'achat on crée de la croissance avec la
croissance on crée de l'emploi pourquoi
n'y a pas d'heure supplémentaire
aujourd'hui mais nos moyens vous voulez
pas demandé c'est parce que comme les
cotisations sociales sont déplafonné
l'entreprise qui donne une heure
supplémentaire doit payer 10% de plus je
propose 25 % plus des cotisations
sociales augmenter à du prg aura pas de
l'augmentation du salaire elle n'a pas
intérêt à les donner et on a fait ce
système invraisemblable que le
contribuable paie 16 milliards pour
financer les 35 heures et en même temps
que les salariés n'ont pas le droit aux
augmentations de salaires dont ils ont
besoin mais je proposerai deux autres
choses pour trouver le plein emploi il
ya cinq cent mille offres d'emploi qui
sont pas satisfaites
je souhaite créer un service public de
l'emploi au fusionnant l'unedic et
l'anpe et je propose parce que dans ma
conception de la république madame royal
il peut pas y avoir des droits sans
devoirs qu'on ne puisse pas lorsqu'on
est chômeur refuser plus de deux offres
d'emploi successives qui correspondent
bien sûr à vos qualifications et à la
région où vous habitez
tous les autres pays le font j'étais au
royaume uni c'est extrêmement
intéressant quand vous êtes chômeur vous
êtes reçu tous les quinze jours dans le
service public d'aujourd'hui le premier
rendez vous pour un chômeur si au bout
de quatre mois et puis je propose une
troisième chose cantonné un minima
social qui n'est pas un seul
bénéficiaire de minima social qui ne
soit pas conduit à exercer une activité
quelle qu'elle soit pour retrouver la
dignité de lui-même et rendre à la
collectivité ce que la collectivité lui
donne par ce système là avec le contrat
de sécurisation professionnelle
ce qui fait qu il n'y aura plus aucun
licenciement économique si je suis
président de la république sans que la
personne licenciée pour délocalisation
par exemple n'est immédiatement un
contrat avec le service public de
l'emploi 90 % du dernier salaire qui lui
permettra de retrouver un emploi ou une
formation avec jean louis borloo nous
l'avons expérimenté dans sept bassins
d'emploi il y en a huit mille qui ont
été signés ça marche le plein emploi
madame royal n'y a aucune raison que ce
soit pour les autres mais si vous
continuez avec les 35 heures dont
j'aimerais que vous nous disiez est ce
que vous les généraliser est ce que vous
les garder ou est ce que comme moi vous
proposer de les garder comme un minimum
est de laisser les gens travailler pour
gagner plus c'est quand même une
question qui intéresse les français a
impressionné
d'abord si vous pensez que les 35 heures
en crée autant de dégâts pourquoi ne les
avez vous pas supprimées pendant ces
cinq années puis je pourquoi ne les avez
vous pas supprimée lorsque vous savez
bien je répondrais parce que allez-y
pourquoi vous ne les avez pas parce que
vous savez bien que ça correspond à un
progrès social vous savez ce que les
gens ont fait du temps libéré après les
35 heures qui d'ailleurs contrairement
ce que vous avez dit en créer plus d'un
million d'emplois
les gens se sont pour 70% d'entre eux
mieux occuper de leurs familles et il ya
beaucoup de femmes en particulier où les
salariés qui ont les travaux les plus
difficiles
qui au bout de 35 heures sont fatigués
et donc l'augmentation de la durée du
travail ne va pas non plus dans le sens
du progrès social moi je suis pour la
liberté de ceux qui veulent travailler
plus et c'est possible on l'a vu puisque
les heures supplémentaires sont
possibles en revanche que ce cours en
revanche sac voulait gagner je les dis
je pense que la deuxième loi sur les 35
heures a été une loi trop rigide donc
vous voyez que je suis capable de
regarder les choses telles qu'elles sont
et la réalité des entreprises telle
qu'elle est parce que je suis au front
avec les entreprises j'ai cette
responsabilité
dans les régions c'est nous qui gérons
les aides économiques aux entreprises
donc tous les jours je suis aux côtés
des chefs d'entreprise et j'ai bien vu
que la deuxième loi sur les 35 heures
avaient été trop rigide et j'ai dit dans
mon pacte présidentiel que désormais
toute modification du code du travail se
ferait après une négociation entre les
partenaires sociaux toute modification
du code du travail et pas comme vous
vous l'avez fait en assénant un certain
nombre de choses vous avez vu les
réactions des abeilles trop rigide
qu'est ce que vous allez modifier dans
le temps de sa cure pour qu'on comprenne
bien les partenaires sociaux en
discuterons et se mettront d'accord et
discuteront branche par branche et s'il
n'y a pas d'accord il n'y aura pas de
nouvelle loi sur les 35 heures est ce
que vous changez de moi je dis voilà les
35 heures comme un minimum je ne
toucherai pas un mal un moyen je garde
les 35 heures comme la durée
hebdomadaire dont java rock donc vous
reconnaissez on est quand même à
promesses sociales et pour moi ce qui
est important mais je vais vous dire je
vais je n'ai sans terminer le tournage
je vais vous donner un exemple parce que
j'étais récemment dans une entreprise de
haute technologie dans la creuse qui
produit des panneaux solaires cette
entreprise et passer aux 32 heures et à
augmenter sa productivité et
contrairement ce que vous avez dit tout
à l'heure parce que j'en ai parlé à rose
et louis zapatero est allé romano prodi
et je suis allé en suède voir la
situation des entreprises dans bien des
entreprises lorsqu'elles sont
performantes sur le plan technologique
elles ont même des durées du travail
inférieure aux 35 heures mais ce
qu'elles font aussi et c'est ça qui est
intéressant mais retrait de violations
plus écrire ses caniches oublié combien
ce mai ils sont admis ce dosser ils sont
payés comme aux 35 heures il donc on
attend quoi mais bon d'achat mais si
pour regarder au blême considérable mais
laissez les gens libres a laissé laisser
les jambes il laissait la liberté des
jeunes eux leur imposez pas les magrets
wire plus pour gagner plus vous savez ce
que c'est la valorisation du travail
c'est un travail payé à sa juste valeur
vous trouvez qu'il est normal que des
salariés commencent leur carrière au
smic à 980 euros net par mois
mines et serbie ne boude pas tant des
questions sur les 35 heures n'ont
jusqu'ici 35 heures ont fait qu'est-ce
que vous changez dans les 35 heures je
n'y comprends rien si si vous avez
parfaitement compris mais vous vous
posez vous faites semblant de ne pas
comprendre ce que j'observe c'est que
vous ne reviendrai pas non plus sur les
35 heures et vous ne les vous ne les
avez pas remise en cause donc elles ne
sont pas responsables de tous les maux
de la terre comme le dit également le
medef j'ai rencontré la présidente du
medef la première chose qu'il m'a dite
c'est revenez sur les 35 heures jeudi
c'est quand même pas sérieux il ya pas
mal d'autres sujets sur lesquels discuté
jeudi voulait qu'on revienne et qu'on
annule les 35 heures elle m'a dit non
donc dont acte c'est donc un acquis
social important mais ça a créé des
difficultés dans des petites entreprises
c'est vrai parce qu'elles ont été
appliquées de façon trop uniforme
donc nous rediscuterons des 35 heures
pour savoir si oui ou non et de quelle
façon elles peuvent être généralisés et
dans quelle branche et ce sera ce seront
les partenaires sociaux qui vont en
discuter je les ai déjà tous reçu les
partenaires sociaux je n'attends pas
d'être élus pour travailler j'ai
rencontré l'ensemble des organisations
syndicales et des organisations
patronales et je leur ai dit que la
réforme profonde du fonctionnement de la
république demain sera une réforme de la
démocratie sociale et je souhaite qu'il
y ait davantage de salariés qui adhèrent
au syndicat pourquoi parce que dans un
pays comme le nôtre où nous n'avons que
8 % de salariés qui adhèrent au syndicat
alors que dans les pays devenus du nord
de l'europe 80% des salariés adhèrent à
une organisation syndicale à ce
moment-là il y à un dialogue social
constructif qui se crée il y à des
compromis sociaux j'étais relations et
les professionnels gtr le bush je
termine sur les 35 heures
supplémentaires je termine sont
aujourd'hui interdites oui ou non je
termine aujourd'hui sur je termine sur
les 35 heures c'est sur le ton de cyril
donc je dis je dis que les partenaires
sociaux parce que le syndicalisme aura
été renforcée par le chèque syndical par
un crédit d'impôt et parce que désormais
ils auront une responsabilité éminente
il n'y aura plus de loi qui sera imposée
dans le domaine social tant qu'il n'y
aura pas eu de discussions entre les
partenaires sociaux et ensuite la loi
viendra consolider ces discussions
apporter les financements nécessaires ou
généralisée le droit du travail et donc
et donc la réponse très précise sur les
35 heures c'est qu'il y aura sur ce
sujet comme sur les autres la
négociation entre partenaires sociaux
branche par branche soit ils se mettent
d'accord et il y aura les 35 heures
soient ils ne se mettent pas d'accord et
il n'y aura pas de généralisation des 35
heures dans les entreprises concernées
mais moi ce que je vais vous dire c'est
que je veux relancer la croissance pas
seulement avec les deux heures
supplémentaires que vous voulez exonérés
avec le chômage que cela va provoquer
puisque comme je l ai dit tout à l'heure
les patrons auront intérêt à donner des
heures supplémentaires que d'ailleurs le
salarié ne peut pas choisir et puis il
faudra du plan de charge pour pouvoir
donner des heures supplémentaires moi je
préfère qu'un employeurs recrutent un
jeune ou un salarié de plus de 50 ans au
chômage plutôt que de donner des heures
supplémentaires exonérées c'est à dire
un nouveau cadeau aux entreprises sans
contrepartie votre mesure coûte 5
milliards d'euros en revanche je pense
que ce qui est très important c'est de
prendre un peu de recul par rapport à
l'enjeu économique est de se dire
aujourd'hui que la vraie bataille c'est
l'économie de la connaissance est ce que
j'ai proposé c'est d'investir
massivement dans l'innovation dans la
recherche
vous le savez les efforts dans la
recherche ont drastiquement diminué je
termine parce que vous avez la même
avance donc il faut écouter le point
sur fond de laquelle point que le
mouvement sauvons la recherche qui ne
voulait appeler pour aucun candidat
vient d'appeler de tirer la sonnette
d'alarmé vient de me soutenir parce
qu'ils savent à quel point la façon dont
vous avez diminué les investissements de
la recherche ont détruit les emplois
d'aujourd'hui et les emplois de demain
je remettrai en reparler mais
c'est le coeur de la patience et c'est
pour ça que je voulais mais c'est sans
qui je pense qu'on va finir ses dires
sur le temps de travail on est ensuite
enchaîné sur leur histoire d'axa bon
alors pouvoir d'achat
sujet à l'autre avec quelques
généralités qui fait que sont pas des
beatles
au fond du sujet justement chacun sa
méthode ces ions voiles et j'ai ma
liberté de parole et vous l'avez merci
alors sage et précis puisque vous
demander de la précision merci je vais
donc pas suivre votre exemple alors
s'agissant des 35 heures qu'est ce qu'on
fait on garde les 35 heures comme durée
demeure d'abord je suis pour une durée
hebdomadaire du travail 35
tout ce qui est travaillé au dessus et
payées 35 39 + 25 % de salaire au delà
39 + 50 % je dis d'ailleurs madame royal
dans le privé comme dans le public
caillet des tout petits salaires dans le
public et il n'est pas admissible qu'on
ne puisse pas donner des heures
supplémentaires et je souhaite qu'on
puisse donner des heures supplémentaires
à des jardinières des cantonner à des
officiers d'état civil à des policiers
municipaux dans nos collectivités
territoriales aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
possible parce qu'au fond il ya une
différence entre vous et moi madame
royal à quoi ça sert les rtt quand on
n'a pas de quoi payer des vacances pour
ses enfants à quoi ça sert les rtt quant
à la fin du mois n'a travaillé tout le
mois et qui reste plus rien il y a un
problème de pouvoir d'achat vous dites
ans c'est formidable j'ai visité notre
prise outright en deux heures oui dit
formidable mais si c'est des petits
salaires c'est pas si formidable que ça
parce que je veux donner la liberté de
choisir aux salariés s'ils ont un
emprunt remboursé maisons à construire
un projet éducatif ou un projet de
vacances laissez les gagner davantage
d'argent s'ils sont d'accord pour
travailler plus deuxième proposition
pour le pouvoir d'achat parce que la
question du pouvoir d'achat est centrale
je propose de conditionner les
allègements de charges branche par
branche à la politique salariale des
banches
fantastique on donne 21 milliards
d'euros d'allègements de charges aux
entreprises à aucun moment l'état ne
discute avec les entreprises branche par
branche de la politique salle rit les
entreprises qui augmenteront les cerner
l'état prendra davantage d'allégements à
sa charge les branches qui ne voudront
pas et qu'ils voudront peut-être
demandant depuis cinq ans c'est de vous
le demander mais face et dans mon projet
pendant le vôtre par 3e 3e et bien sûr
la modulation des aides en fonction de
la masse salariale troisième élément je
souhaite que l'impôt sur les bénéfices
payés par les sociétés soient moins
importants pour les sociétés qui
investissent en france et qui créent de
l'emploi en france est plus important
pour celles qui ne le font pas dernier
point je propose que les entreprises
soient mises devant leurs
responsabilités
ça suffit maintenant de mettre dehors
les gens de 50 ans on peut plus faire
financer par le contribuable
les préretraites à guichet ouvert il ya
cinq milliards d'euros d'économies on ne
peut pas dire aux français qu'on va
vivre plus longtemps vous devez cotiser
plus longtemps pour la retraite et dans
le même temps conduire des entreprises a
poussé à la retraite des quinquagénaires
qui ont encore beaucoup de choses à
donner à leur pays à leur entreprise et
laurent peau voilà très exactement ce
que je vais essayer de faire pour
résoudre le problème du pouvoir d'achat
pour résoudre le problème de la
croissance avec un service public de
l'emploi rénover des droits madame royal
mais aussi des devoirs parce que sans
devoir ne peut pas y avoir de droit on
va faire une petite pause et je vais
vous poser à tous les deux la même
question puisqu'on est à peu près sur
les mêmes temps de parole sur les
sécurités que vous pouvez apporter en
matière de santé en matière de logement
matière de retraite
vous pouvez commencer ma main d'abord
sur la question des droits et des
devoirs je voyais un point sur lequel
nous sommes d'accord et dans le
programme d'ailleurs que je propose il
n'y a aucun droit nouveau sans une
contrepartie c'est à dire on est dans le
donnant-donnant dans le gagnant gagnant
et sur cette question là je pense que la
première des sécurités c'est la sécurité
du salaire et c'est la sécurité du
pouvoir d'achat et moi je propose de
revaloriser le smic et les bas salaires
c'est à dire que dès l'élection se
réunissent la conférence nationale sur
la croissance et les salaires avec les
partenaires sociaux pour décider de
l'augmentation des basses parce que nous
sommes un des pays d'europe où les bas
salaires sont les plus bas d'europe et
je pense que la croissance économique
dépend de la redistribution du pouvoir
d'achat sur les bas salaires et ce sera
l'une de mes priorités sur l'autre
question parce que je voudrais quand
même revenir encore un instant sur la
relance économique je crois que ces
problèmes dans pas trop longtemps sous
la forme juste une chose très envie que
je crois beaucoup dans la dynamique des
territoires et dans la capacité des
français à créer des entreprises je veux
que le peuple français deviennent un
peuple d'entrepreneurs et pour cela dans
les pôles de compétitivité qui sont
maintenant dans toutes les régions et
sur les quais et sur lesquels nous avons
attendu et j'en sais quelque chose en
tant que présidente de région pendant
trois ans l'aide de l'état qui n'est pas
venu et bien moi je m'inspirais avec
l'ensemble des 26 régions de france et
quand tu ne nous allons déployer cette
force cette énergie des territoires
parce qu'enfin la chef de l'état que je
serai avec l'ensemble des présidents de
région enfin vont tirer dans la même
direction ce qui n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui songez que j'ai attendu deux
ans avant d'avoir l'accord du
gouvernement auquel vous appartenez pour
pouvoir ouvrir une usine de
biocarburants à la rochelle deux ans
d'attentes d'une autorisation
administrative moi je veux
débureaucratiser l'état et faire en
sorte que ce soit les régions qui
souhaitent en première ligne avec les
universités et les centres de recherche
et je transférer les ressources parce
que c'est là que les chefs d'entreprise
peuvent se mettre ensemble dans les
pôles de compétitivité dans les réseaux
d'entreprises dans chaque université
auquel je vais donner de l'autonomie il
y aura des pépinières d'entreprises et
chaque jeune diplômé qui va sortir de
l'université aura accès à un prêt
gratuit aura accès à ce service donné
par l'entreprise et par l'université
pour créer son activité son emploi sa
petite entreprise et je pense que c'est
comme cela aussi que nous remettrons en
mouvement les talents de nos territoires
il y a du potentiel considérable il ya
aujourd'hui des gens désespérés nos
chercheurs s'en vont à l'étranger
et il fut aux états unis où ils sont
payés trois à quatre fois plus cher
qu'en france nous sommes en train de
perdre notre matière grise et bien moi
je serai la présidente de la république
qui fera en sorte que la matière grise
de la france restent en france qui fera
en sorte que les jeunes diplômés est
envie de créer leur entreprise qui fera
en sorte que les pôles de compétitivité
c'est à dire les entreprises
d'aujourd'hui de demain les industries
de la connaissance qui sont aujourd'hui
même menacé par les délocalisations car
quand vous voyez entreprises comme
alcatel qui délocalisent alors je dis
que la situation est très dangereuse car
avant c'était les entreprises à bas
salaires qui était délocalisé
aujourd'hui sont touchés les entreprises
de haute technologie et donc le moment
est urgent il faut faire autrement il
faut voir l'économie autrement il faut
l'avoir en dynamique avec les
territoires en rassemblant en réunissant
la recherche la formation et
l'entreprise et je pense que c'est comme
cela que nous déploierons les énergies
parce que pour apporter une réponse j'en
ai juste un mot au sécurité dernière
ascension
mais bien les juger et non je parle et
que je sais que ce que je dis je le
réaliserai parce que je le vois déjà
fonctionné sur les territoires et que je
suis allé dans les autres pays voir ce
qui marche moi je serai la présidente de
ce qui marche sans oeillères dont en
regardant tout ce qui peut fonctionner
et c'est comme ça je crois que je re
débloquerait la machine économique
évidemment ce test sur les
hautes-pyrénées
512 marche ben moi je voudrais être le
président qui fasse que ce qui marche
pas marche bon parce que si c'est pour
être la présidente de ce qui va qui a
pas de problème c'est pas la peine les
gens votent pas pour nous pour qu'on
aille compliqué ce qui va mais au
contraire pour qu'on répare ce qui va
pas alors d'abord sur les pôles de
compétitivité coût est personne honnête
reconnaissait que les pôles de
compétitivité bon qui les a créées les
entreprises abandonna l'épave ou non le
fruit sans les entreprises alors ne vous
attribuez vous même ce sont les réseaux
de chefs d'entreprise à domme étions
attendus hélas longtemps et qui
aujourd'hui n'ont toujours pas les
avants ciel jusqu'au que vous aviez
promis et moi je leur donnerai madame la
nouvelle politique une politique moderne
c'est l'honnêteté oui pôles de
compétitivité ont été créés en 2004 à la
suite du rapport parlementaire
remarquable de christian blanc et c'est
à partir de ce moment là que les tâches
et ministre des finances les a créés
pourquoi ça pouvait pas être les régions
parce que les pôles de compétitivité
sont des exonérations fiscales et
sociales qui ne seraient décidés dans
les régions jour par l'état ils
ressentent toujours plein mais si c'est
très important et un anneau pas peu
importe mais peu importe la famille est
un art c'est suffit il suffit d'être
honnête oui il ya des choses bien que
vous avez fait il ya des choses bien que
nous fait ça ne sert à rien de le
contester alors sur la nationalité doit
s que les exonérations fiscales sont
arrivés bien sûr madame non elles ne
sont pas à dire 60 je le sais je suis
présidente de région excusez moi ce
n'est pas exact il ya 68 pôles de
compétitivité aucune généralisée icahn
est labellisé oui ce n'est pas une
conférence de presse oui non madame ce
n'est pas exact ça fonctionne ça marche
et c'est d'ailleurs parce que ça marche
que vous en parler car si ça marchait
pas vous n'auriez pas par les halos gens
passionnés par d'arvor dans un poser des
questions santé logement retraite est un
sujet extrêmement précis pour les
retraites est une question essentielle
c'est la retraite par répartition il
faut la garantie les lois fillon ont
permis de rééquilibrer les qualités
entre les salariés du privé les salariés
du public qui m'attend cotisent 40 ans
grâce aux lois fillon jusqu'en 2020 on
n'a pas de souci majeur à avoir au film
quant au financement de nos retraites je
garantirai l'application des lois fillon
madame royal a dit qu'elle les démonter
le ray on verra comment elle finance
deuxième élément il y à un ensemble de
régimes de retraite qui n'ont pas été
réformé c'est ce qu'on appelle les
régimes spéciaux moi je respect que les
gens qui adhèrent aux régimes spéciaux
edf sncf ratp mais dans un pays où huit
ex cris égalité sur le frontispice de
nos établissements publics il est quand
même curieux d'expliquer que certains
français doivent cotiser trente sept
années et demie pour avoir leur retraite
alors que les autres cotisent 40 ans je
réformerai les régimes spéciaux
par souci d'égalité
deuxième élément il ya trois millions de
petites retraites c'est à dire 3
millions de personnes qui sont en
dessous du minimum vieillesse
j'augmenterais de 25% les petites
retraites et jeffrey financer parce
qu'on aura récupéré sur la réforme des
régimes spéciaux troisièmement je veux
mettre sur la table la question des
pensions de réversion la situation faite
aux veuves est catastrophique ces 54 %
aujourd'hui quant à marie des scènes la
veuve à 54 % de la pension je porterai à
60% comme un premier élément la question
des retraites est centrale deuxième
élément le logement la question est
posée mon ambition serait de faire de la
france un pays de propriétaires
il ya un français sur deux qui sont
propriétaires de leur logement
il ya 80 % des espagnols qui sont
propriétaires de logements qu'à 76 % des
anglais qui sont propriétaires de leur
logement il ya 12 millions de familles
françaises qui aimeraient propriétaire
et qui ne l'est pas dès l'été 2007 je
créerai un crédit d'impôt qui permettra
pour ceux qui paient l'impôt sur le
revenu de déduire les intérêts de
l'emprunt pour acheter leur appartement
de leurs revenus et pour ceux qui ne le
paie pas un crédit d'impôt c'est à dire
l'état qui leur prend bourgeois il faut
qu'on favorise la propriété pour les
français deuxième élément pour ceux qui
n'ont pas de relations je crée un
système de cautionnement public pour
leur permettre d'emprunter troisième
élément je veux revenir sur cette
injustice invraisemblable qui fait quand
vous empruntez on vous demande une
visite médicale et lorelei à un
thérapeute est malade parce que si vous
êtes malade on veut bien vous prêter
mais ça vous coûte plus cher c'est
scandaleux c'est pas parce qu'on est
malade qu'on n'a pas le droit de se
loger dernier point sur la santé je
pense que sur la santé il faut créer un
cinquième risque le risque de la
dépendance
parce qu'une société qui s'occupe pas
des personnes âgées c'est une société
qui se redit qui perd son humanité je
veux engager un plan contre alzheimer
890 milles français touchées par
alzheimer aujourd'hui j'ai vu dans une
maison à en bretagne 1 k monsieur de 63
ans agriculteur toute sa vie en une ans
il est devenu totalement autres nous
reconnaissons plus les siens ça va
concerner dans dix ans un million deux
cent mille français il faut engager un
plan contre l'alzheimer pour trouver
l'origine de cette maladie comme on a
fait un plan cancer et je veux enfin
poser la question du remboursement des
prothèses dentaires
c'est pas un luxe et du remboursement
des lunettes c'est un luxe voilà pour
répondre précisément aux trois
préoccupations qui était le vôtre
monsieur royal sur le même thème sur les
sécurités sur ces trois thèmes et d'une
manière
vous financier tout cela puisque
parallèlement vous avez annoncé une
baisse de 4 points je crois des
prélèvements obligatoires c'est à dire
72 milliards d'euros soit moins de
recettes sont tuées 72 certains
économistes ont évalué à 72 68 enfin
c'est déjà considérable
8 milliards d'euros en moins et
l'ensemble des dépenses que vous venez
et la d'énumérer mais c'est maintenant
je pose simplement la question parce
qu'on leur a posé la question pour marc
pons à la fois se plaindre de la dette
monsieur est additionné cher expliqué
additionnez les dépenses je dis cela
parce que les vous que je fasse je dis
cela parce que quand est ce qu'on
voulait que je le fasse non non je vais
bon je vais venir plus précisément
aurait demandé d'être précise lorsque
vous dites par exemple vous allez
financer l'augmentation des petites
retraites par la réforme des régimes
spéciaux
vous savez très bien que la réforme des
régimes spéciaux va prendre un certain
temps et donc il ya là comme un tour de
passe-passe vous ne dit pas combien de
temps cela va prendre il va y avoir des
discussions il va y avoir des remises à
plat moi je veut revaloriser tout de
suite dès mon élection
les petites retraites parce que je pense
parce que je pense je vous le dis je
vais vous le dire
je mets des fonds supplémentaires au
fonds de réserve des retraites très bien
je le fais par une taxe sur les revenus
boursiers parce que je pense en effet il
faut de la justice les partenaires
sociaux en discuterons mais au moins le
principe est là et nous aller combien
sur le fond je je vous donne déjà les
principes ah bon parce que vous savez
que sur le fond il ya 32 milliards je
vous donne des 6 milliards mais ces
moines laissez-moi financer de vote
actuellement moi j'ai une recette elle
va elle va vous avant on en attendait ça
c'est très intéressant cette taxe que
vous nous annoncez
lorsque lionel jospin a créé ce fonds il
a prévu 120 milliards d'aud y en a 36
chaque année l'état en mai six votre
taxe à peu près c'est combien mais ma
taxe elle sera au niveau de ce qui sera
nécessaire pour faire de la justice
sociale car une part c'est une prévision
vous levez recentrer une partie oui vous
pouvez pas d'envié un chiffre non je ne
peux pas vous dire dechy pourquoi
pourquoi je ne veux pas vous dire le
chiffre parce que c'est votre la relance
oui c'est mon droit parce que la relance
de la croissance économique va aussi
permettre des cotisations
supplémentaires
moi je crois que la croissance et donc
je crois l'un des chanteurs français le
montant de cette taxe et l'espérance de
recettes oui parce que je dis aux
français avec se remettra-t-il pour
l'équilibré de nos régimes de retraite
parfaitement ah oui on est tranquille
pour l'équipe de nos régimes de retraite
parce que moi au moins j'ai une recette
mais ce que je veux dire globalement sur
cette question des retraites c'est que
c'est une question essentielle pourquoi
parce que c'est la solidarité entre
générations
et ce que l'on voit aujourd'hui c'est le
fait que les petites retraites font
basculer des millions de personnes dans
la pauvreté pourquoi parce que le
pouvoir d'achat des petites retraites a
baissé et je me suis engagé à réformer
l'indicé des prix car l' indice des prix
ne calcule pas exactement ce que
consomment les personnes âgées et donc
je veux que l'indexation des retraites
suivent vraiment la consommation des
personnes âgées je vois de plus en plus
de personnes dans mes permanences qui ne
font plus qu'un repas par jour il y à
des femmes qui partent à la retraite
avec un niveau de retraite à peine
supérieur au minimum vieillesse parce qu
elles se sont interrompues
pour élever leurs enfants et que la
réforme de la loi fillon a créé une
injustice insupportable aux dépens des
femmes parce qu'en allongeant la durée
de cotisation est la frapper les femmes
qui se sont arrêtées pour élever leurs
enfants je pense aussi aux femmes qui
ont élevé leurs enfants tout simplement
locaux pension de réversion ou même à la
façon dont ils vont garder même à la
maison ou même à la non je remet à plat
les lois fibre ne serait ce que pour
cette question de l'injustice si je
comprends bien madame messieurs à vous
c'est moi qui s'est pointé à vous
augmentez les retraites mais ce qui
avait été fait comme financement grâce
aux doigts fillon vous leur mettez à
plein je râlais détruisez non c'est pas
au kg sera selon monsieur leur
permettait quand monsieur hollande
annonce une cg pour payer les retraites
vous confirmez ou vous infirmez est-ce
que je peux me permettre de finir le
déroulement de ma pensée oui je remet à
plat les lois fillon ça ne veut pas dire
que nous détruisons tous nous remettons
à plat et nous discutons avec les
partenaires sociaux pour moi parce que
les lois fillon on crée des injustices
et en particulier des injustices faites
aux femmes et moi je pense qu'on garde
les 4,6 et de matière on parce que je
suis très bien la technique deuxièmement
nous prendrons en compte la pénibilité
des tâches je souhaite qu'ils aient des
retraites à la carte que ceux qui
veulent travailler plus longtemps plus
le faire mais que ceux qui sont fatigués
parce qu'ils ont eu des métiers
extrêmement difficiles puissent
s'arrêter plus tôt entre un ouvrier et
un cadre supérieur il y a une espérance
de vie de sept années d'écart une
espérance de vie vous entendez de cette
année d'écart dans la france
d'aujourd'hui est ce que cela vous
trouvez que c'est juste et en plus cette
qualité de vie elle n'est pas la même
selon que l'on a subi les accidents du
travail la pénibilité des tâches il ya
aujourd'hui en france 2000 accidents du
travail par jour là aussi il ya des
réserves de croissance si on lutte
contre les accidents du travail et
contre les maladies professionnelles
donc c'est une globalité de la proche de
la question des retraites c'est à la
fois la qualité de la retraite le niveau
du revenu auquel est pris sa retraite
les droits des femmes la question aussi
des femmes qui n'ont jamais travaillé et
je pense à elle dans la france
d'aujourd'hui parce que je crois que
choisir d'avoir élevé ses enfants c'est
aussi le plus beau des métiers quand on
a choisi cela or si l'on finit sa vie
dans la pauvreté au minimum vieillesse
ça n'est pas juste et donc moi je veux
là aussi rediscuter avec les partenaires
sociaux de quelle façon nous pouvons
prendre en compte ce travail maternelle
qui a été fait et qui aujourd'hui n'est
pas reconnu voilà ce que je compte
remettent sur la table et en effet
j'espère que par la relance de la
croissance nous aurons des recettes au
niveau des cotisations et si ça ne
suffit pas nous ferons une taxe sur les
revenus boursiers voilà comment je vois
la réforme des retraites qui est en
effet un des sujets de société les plus
importants indiqué parce que pour la
première fois pour la première fois on
voit en france des jeunes qui sont
inquiets de leur retraite alors qu'il y
en ait fait quelques années ça n'était
pas une idée qui leur est fleuret les
souris est donc dans les silences entre
vous au détriment de nicolas sarkozy
donc
sur la fiscalité ce binôme les paris cet
intérêt c'est un point extrêmement
important qui devrait me semble t'il
faire consensus entre la gauche et la
droite
comment finance-t-on nous retraite ça
devrait pas être un sujet de bagarres
politiques managériales ça doit être un
sujet me semble-t-il d'état où
l'ensemble de la classe politique
républicaine devrait s'additionner pour
trouver des solutions alors commence à
lancer gharb toxines et
les lois fillon ça consistait à passer à
40 années dans un premier temps 41 dans
un deuxième temps de cotisation
l'idée de françois fillon qui tue les
des justes et puisqu'on va vivre plus
longtemps il faut cotiser plus longtemps
pour payer les retraites ça me semble un
6 1 non ça dépend de la pénibilité du
travail je suis désolé penne big bang il
ya un écart d'espérance de vie tels que
je viens de vous les non c'est très
injuste nationalement d uniformiser
cotisations et moi je pourrais t'en
rends compte la pénibilité du travail
d'harcourt décidé à plaider la durée de
cotisation militer du travail déjà pris
en compte comme vous le savez dans les
lois fillon mais vous savez parfaitement
que la pénibilité du travail ne résout
pas tous les problèmes nous vivons plus
longtemps il va falloir cotiser plus
longtemps oui ou non sommes-nous
capables
gauche et droite de nous mettre d'accord
sur cette idée simple que tous les pays
développés au monde augmente la durée de
cotisation pour prendre sa retraite il
faut le faire en france quand vous dites
je vais remettre à plat loi fillon c'est
à dire que vous revenez sur ce qui a été
le travail du gouvernement balladur et
du gouvernement raffarin pour obtenir le
financement des reins de nos régimes de
retraite je vous le dis c'est
irresponsable deuxième élément mais le
financement n'est pas résolu vous le
savez très bien le financier résulats
jusqu'en 2020 madame o t il et régionaux
n'est pas résolu il savait très bien
mais non madame l'écouté ça c'est
quelque chose qui n'est contesté par
personne les lois fillion tout
l'évangile toutes les branches de la
sécurité sociale sont en défilant mais
madame toutes les branches et tous les
comptes sociaux sont en déficit enfin
bon si vous permettez manager breton pas
sur les chivas que je crois que les
français attendent un débat d'un autre
niveau mais c'est un débat d'un très bon
niveau que ce soit comment on va
financer les retraites madame
d'un pardon de vous le dire vous faites
une erreur le financement des retraites
est équilibré jusqu'à l'horizon 2020
premier point voulait tout remettre à
plat c'est à dire tout le travail qui a
été fait voulait le démolir 12e - les
remettre à plat la démolit les régimes
spéciaux oui et moi régimes spéciaux là
ça n'est pas du tout je voulais pas
réformer les régimes spéciaux réformés
les régimes qui conduit le vôtre ah ben
voilà le bien le mien de celui du
parlementaire je suis pas parlementaire
l'heureux je n'avais pas été
parlementaire gym fun et bien l'homme
jamais droit est bien aussi et woody que
votre votre parce que vous ne changez
pas vous ne parlez jamais de régime
spécial des parlementaires dont celui ci
si je le remets chapeau les bat très
bien alain vous vous le ferez il n'y a
aucun problème là et je serais d'accord
des coups mais il vous annonce est donc
aux adhérents régimes spéciaux que vous
allez faire la réforme des régimes
spéciaux mais bien sûr et rennes n'a
jamais été humain voilà c'est qu'un
c'est les régimes spéciaux seront mis
dans la discussion des retraites alors
mais évidemment c'est un point qui me
semble-t-il extrêmement important il a
toujours été dit sans et s'en rend la
question de monsieur richard o sur les
régimes spéciaux attend sur la question
crier rose il s agit pas ici il s'agit
pas je n'oppose pas non mais moi les uns
aux autres mais moi non plus vous sera
mis à plat donc y compris les régimes
spéciaux quand y'en a qui cotisent
trente sept années et demie quand
d'autres cotisent 40 ans et pas crier
haro sur ceux qui cotisent 37 admis que
de leur dire 10 dont l'égalité dans la
france d'aujourd'hui c'est que vous
cotisez comme les autres bon sur l'idée
de françois hollande de créer une cg
supplémentaires et vous ferez un débat
avec françois hollande avant vos l'oeuf
camp voulait soit concerné voilà ça ne
vous engage pas non très bien il sera
content de l'apprendre et je serai
j'aurais au moins facilité cette part de
du dialogue s'agissant attendait 10 ans
les choses telles qu'elles sont je ne
vais moins ça n'est pas ma conception du
pouvoir que de décider de façon
péremptoire et unilatérale comment nous
allons régler ses problèmes je voulais
dit ce sont d'abord les partenaires
sociaux qui vont discuter avec l'état
bien sûr il y aura des réunions
tripartites pas moi je le considère dans
la pub les jurys idée de comment on
finance je voulais tu es bien je suis
pressé par quelque chose d'autre et bien
je vous les ai données je voulais vous
étonnez pas de je vous ai déjà fait 200
deal vous avez avancé madame c'est une
taxe dont vous avez refusé de nous dire
le montant l'assiette et et la recette
est la deuxième idée vous avez avancé
c'est la mise à plat de la loi fillon je
vous reconnais une troisième idée c'est
une grande discussion c'est la sixième
ou septième depuis qu'on dépense en ans
et l'a fait à masquer ution la grande
discussion il faut qu'elle débouche sur
quelque chose il ya des millions de
retraités qui se disent et des millions
de salariés qui se disent moi j'ai trimé
toute ma vie j'entends qu'on équilibre
mon régime de retraite et avoir ma
pension avec moi comme président de la
république les choses sont parfaitement
claires elles seront en ordre on
financera et on s'engage alors avec elle
rien sur la fiscalité n'est pas pareil
de l'art sèche lesquels compte quelle
nouvelle cotisation madame n'y a pas
besoin de cotisation parce que la loire
filiation non madame puisque je ne
remets pas plein la loi fillon les
recettes et sont très simples mais ça
vous n'êtes pas très bonne est peut-être
pas suivi exactement le débat les lois
fillon on ya trois solutions pour le
régime doit soit vous laissez les
pensions de retraite il n'est pas
question qu'elles sont déjà trop petit
soit vous augmenter les cotisations paye
les salariés il n'en est pas question
sont trop lourdes soit vous augmenter la
durée de cotisation c'est les lois
fillon comme moi je garde les lois
fillon j'ai pas besoin d'une grosse
recette supplémentaire vous avez déjà
d'une recette supplémentaire parce que
vous démantelez les lois fille voilà le
problème à leurs jeunes voulaient je ne
peux pas vous laisser dire des choses
qui sont inexactes je ne démantèle pas
les lois fillon vous les remettez à plat
je les remets à plat et je met fin aux
insuffisances et je met fin aux
injustices les plus criantes
celle que j'ai évoqué tout à l'heure la
prise en compte de la pénibilité
je mets une possibilité de retraite à la
carte et je répare les injustices faites
aux femmes et ensuite je regarde quels
sont les besoins de financement et moi
aussi je garantis le financement des
régimes de retraite éventuellement par
une ressource nouvelle mais avant de
savoir s'il faut de ressources nouvelles
je regarde aussi ce que me donne les
recettes tirées de la relance de la
croissance voilà comment je tiens à lorp
la cohérence le président n'arrivera pas
à vous mettre d'accord sur les retraites
et qu'on a parlé recettes donc de
fiscalité donnez-nous nikolic dans une
collision qui vous était causé tout à
l'heure par ségolène royal votre avis
sur le visage d'un impôt et sur la
faisabilité de ce que vous proposez les
la question des baisses d'impôts mais je
n'en fais pas du tout un homme real est
un problème idéologique
j'essaie de regarder les choses avec
pragmatisme avec bon sens
nous sommes le pays d'europe où les
impôts les plus élevés
qu'est ce que l'europe la liberté de
circulation des hommes des femmes et des
capitaux on peut pas refaire l'europe et
avant les impôts les plus élevés qu'est
ce que j'ai dit nous avons 68 milliards
d'impôts de plus
que ce que payent la moyenne des 15 pays
les plus riches de l'union européenne
donc il faut revenir à la moyenne le
problème de la france c'est qu'on paie
trop d'impôts que les charges entre
l'eau qu'est-ce que ça aboutit quel
résultat tout ça c'est pas un problème
de libéralisme c'est pas un problème
d'idéologie c'est comme nous sommes dans
un monde ouvert si le travail est trop
taksim dans le travail s'en va si
capital madame est trop taxer le capital
s'en va si à plus de capital il ya plus
de travail il ya plus sens donc tout le
problème de la france c'est de
comprendre madame que nous sommes dans
un environnement concurrentiel et qu'on
ne peut pas imposer à nos entreprises
des impôts plus lourds que ce que paient
les entreprises concurrentes dans les
pays voisins on ne peut pas imposer aux
contribuables français des impôts et des
prélèvements plus lourd que ce qu'on
paye dans les autres pays il faut donc
face à ça d'une manière ou d'une autre
réduire le train de vie de l'état
réduire les dépenses publiques être plus
productifs faire mieux avec moins pour
alléger le poids de la fiscalité tels
qu'ils pèsent aujourd'hui sur le travail
c'est notamment la raison pour laquelle
je propose qu'on taxe les importations
pour qu'elles financent la protection
sociale des français la question de la
fiscalité c'est même plus une question
de gauche droite c'est pas une question
de socialisme libéraliste c'est une
question d'efficacité dans le monde
ouvert qu'est l'autre et c'est pour ça
que j'ai proposé de ne pas remplacer un
départ sur deux à la retraite que je des
fonctionnaires que j'ai proposé de
supprimer tous les organismes qui me
servent à rien una multiplient un
certain nombre d'agents sont aujourd'hui
il faut les supprimer et que j'ai
procédé que j'ai proposé si je suis élu
président de la république la mise en
place systématique d'une politique
d'évaluation de toutes les politiques
publiques
vous avez parlé de la formation
professionnelle vous avez parfaitement
raison il ya des guerres de productivité
fenomeno dans ce domaine sur la
fiscalité et puis après on passera un
autre grand chantier quel dommage que
vous n'ayez pas fait tout ça pendant
cinq ans hélas que c'est vrai sur
l'évaluation des politiques publiques
c'est le parlement qui normalement a les
moyens de faire cela et vous savez la
difficulté avec laquelle il a accès aux
différents compte réduire le train de
vie de l'état oui c'est ce que je me
faudra c'est que le président de la
commission des finances à l'assemblée
soit un membre de l'opposition je trouve
que c'est une ouverture pour une
république irréprochable et vous savez
très bien aussi que c'est une idée qui
est dans le pacte présidentiel
c'est très bien pour me rejoignent et
ses bas record
l'avez vous fait pendant sept ans voilà
ce que pendant cinq ans vous avez mais
tous les pouvoirs vous avez je rejoins y
vous allécher
sur la musicalité ya un problème de
crédibilité
voyez-vous parce que quand on a pu
pendant cinq ans éventuellement haute
saône et une certaine pas moi vous dites
sommes donné une telle place à
l'opposition c'était pour
l'international pourquoi ne l'avez vous
pas fait vous n'êtes pas crédible à
l'oeuvre de christian dente impartiale
au problème de crédibilité vous me le
dites comme cette même passer en force
avec les 49 les bras donc on en revient
à la réforme des institutions
parce que je crois en effet que cette
question sérieusement
sur la fiscalité ma priorité sera la
baisse de la fiscalité sur l'écologie je
veux une réforme fiscale très importante
sur tout ce qui a de près ou de loin une
relation avec la construction des
emplois dans le domaine de
l'environnement et de l'écologie et je
veut négocier avec les autres pays
européens une tva tendant vers zéro pour
développer les énergies renouvelables
les éco matériaux pour lancer un plan
massif d'isolation des logements déjà
construits puisque dans ces domaines et
notamment dans les métiers du bâtiment
dans l'agriculture également dans toutes
les technologies liées à l'eau au sol au
paysage
nous pouvons et dans les énergies
renouvelables telles que je viens de le
dire nous pouvons si nous avons une
fiscalité très encourageante développer
je pense plusieurs centaines de milliers
d'emplois voilà quelle sera ma priorité
dans le domaine de la réforme fiscale je
l' ai dit tout à l'heure aussi pour les
pme qu'ils réinvestiront leurs bénéfices
dans l'entreprise
l'impôt sur les sociétés sera divisé par
deux parce que je crois que c'est là que
se trouve le ressort de la croissance
économique enfin je veux un impôt juste
et quand je vois que le bouclier fiscal
que vous venez d'instaurer vient
d'autoriser une ristourne de 7 millions
d'euros à une personne d'ailleurs cas du
est même très surprise de recevoir ses 7
millions d'euros au nom du bouclier
fiscal jeudi en effet qu'il faut faire
attention aux injustices fiscales et à
la façon dont vous voulez en effet
exonérée un certain nombre de
patrimoines élevé je crois que la
fiscalité c'est d'abord un outil au
service du développement économique
et puis c'est quelque chose qui doit
être juste et qui doit être bien compris
par les français qui doit être
transparent et dans les règles doivent
être claires et en face sur la question
du logement puisque cette question a été
évoquée tout à l'heure il ya aujourd'hui
en france plus de trois millions et demi
de français qui sont mal logées ils sont
mal logées parce que le plan de
construction des logements sociaux et
est insuffisant et notamment dans
certaines communes qui ne respectent pas
la loi et je dis que demain l'état
prendra ses responsabilités construira
les logements sociaux dans les communes
telles que la vôtre qui ne respectent
pas la loi parce que je crois aussi que
quand on est candidat à la présidence de
la république on doit montrer l'exemple
et appliquer la loi dans l'exercice de
ses fonctions exécutives et notamment
sur le territoire dont on a la charge je
ferai aussi en sorte que dans les
logements sociaux les locataires qui
payent leur loyer et leur charge
régulièrement pendant 15 ans puisse
devenir propriétaires de leur logement
et enfin je créerai le service public de
la caution parce qu'on voit beaucoup de
petits salariés ou de jeunes en
particulier ou ceux qui subissent des
discriminations qui n'arrivent pas à
accéder aux logements locatifs parce
qu'il faut sortir de sa poche trois mois
de loyer alors nous créerons un service
public de la caution c'est à dire une
garantie donnée aux assurances qui
pourront faire la vence propriétaires de
ces trois mois pour que en effet il y
ait sur le marché de la location
beaucoup plus de 2 fluidité voilà je
crois le dispositif pour l'emploi pour
le pôle logement qui est en effet à
leurs 24 19 en effet un des problèmes
les plus épuisés nouzaret encore 3000 a
été beaucoup de juger un mot sur une
expression que les français ont
peut-être
mal compris s'il bouclier fiscal si je
suis président de la république je
fixerai un bouclier fiscal à 50% mon
idée c'est que nulle en france ne doit
se voir prélever plus de la moitié de ce
qu'il a gagné dans l'année au fond on
travaillerait du 1er janvier au 31 au 30
juin pour l'état et à partir du 1er
juillet jusqu'au 31 décembre pour sa
famille ça me semble raisonnable
le but de la france c'est pas de faire
partir tous ceux qui veulent créer
innover on a besoin de gens qui créent
des richesses il pas simplement de les
faire partir tous enrichir les autres
pays un mot sur la fiscalité de l'enviro
même qu'il faut tenir compte du
patrimoine mais bien sûr j'ai trouvé
normal que cette dame est recherché
c'est jeu je connais ça mais si je
connais pas si ça a été publié
aujourd'hui au journal c'est bien de
madame cette dame une riche héritière b
mais madrid qui vient de toucher un
chèque au mur des maires du bouclier
fiscal à 60% est applicable depuis le
1er janvier mais avant cela attendait ne
faisons pas de remarquables nominem
c'est désagréable je vais regarder ce
choc a bien volontiers c'est la
conséquence de ce que vous avez pris vos
noms et parce que moi je propose c'est
pire je propose à s'inscrire pour se
raser avec des ans tout comme sa
poussette même leur dire voilà
aujourd'hui à 60 parce que moi je
considérais je vous lis bien en face
madame je considère qu un pays libre
c'est un pays où chacun put d'ipo
disposer librement de la moitié de ce
qu'il a gagné du tout des gens d'une
perception madame ses cuisses et ses
enfants comme un tri moi non si ce sont
des petits que je peux terminer
maintenant et ses trésors ça c'est une
première chose c'est pas du tout et juge
cette dame des landes euros de
patrimoine je confierais pas grâce à
vous un chèque de 7 concert de
célébration une relation si ça soit
écrasé peut-être mieux que moi grâce au
bouclier fiscal oui je sais je reste au
bouclier fiscal c'est que françois
hollande a dit qu'il aimait pas les
riches qui était d'ailleurs une
expression curieuse surtout quand on
fixait le riche à 4000 euros vous vous
trouvez ça veut dire qu'il n'aime pas
toutes personnes qui gagnent plus de
4000 euros il doit passer mais lui même
parce que si en plus c'est pas beau bon
alors deuxième élément très important la
fiscalité n'est pas là il part contexte
la fiscalité écologique ça ce n'est pas
l'environnement et 13 et du drac de
nicolas hulot ou l'aveyron on peut se
retrouver d'ailleurs madame mais moi je
demanderais nos partenaires européens
que sur tous les produits propres on ait
une fiscalité à taux réduit c'est très
important c'est quand même pas normal
que quand on veut acheter une voiture
qui pollue pas ça coûte plus cher qu'une
voiture qui qui qui qui pollue en
mettant la tva à 5,5 sur les produits
propres on diminue le prix des produits
propres et on incite les français à en
acheter
pareil pour le bâtiment je proposerai la
tva à taux réduit 5 % pour tous les
bâtiments qu'on appelle hq haute qualité
environnementale deuxième élément je
trouve scandaleux qu'on importe en
france des produits qui viennent de pays
qui respecte pas le protocole de kyoto
c'est à dire vous savez ce fameux
histoire d effet de serre des gaz à
effet de serre il faut créer la taxe
carbone pour rééquilibrer la concurrence
avec nos propres industriel parce que
nous on fabrique des produits qui
respectent le protocole de kyoto et ont
fait venir des produits qui ne
respectent pas ces la taxe carbone
troisième chose je souhaite pense compte
créer une taxe sur les poids lourds
étrangers la suisse vient de décider de
ne pas accepter sur son territoire les
polos
l'allemagne vient de faire pareil ya
aucune raison qu'on se récupère la
totalité du trafic autoroutier poids
lourds d'europe alors s'agissant
d'ailleurs de l'environnement je veux
dire prenant mes responsabilités que si
je suis président de la république je
confirmerai le choix du nucléaire
savez vous madame que la france produit
21 % de gaz à effet de serre de moins
par tête d'habitant aps la moyenne des
pays d'europe il ya une raison à cela
c'est que nous avons le nucléaire que le
nucléaire c'est une énergie propre bien
sûr qu'il faut développer les énergies
renouvelables l'éolien corker on peut
pas couvrir la france des éoliennes
lorsque vous les voyez vous voyez bien
que ça pose aussi des questions sur le
paysage le solaire les biocarburants
dont j'ai proposé la défiscalisation à
100% parce que je crois à l'agriculture
française je veux que les agriculteurs
français les paysans français puissent
vivre de leur travail avec des prix qui
leur soit 40 et dans une europe qui fait
la préférence communautaire alors
s'agissant des des logements sociaux
devraient dire un mot bien sûr que c'est
important les logements sociaux mais
pour moi c'est plus importantes
permettent aux français de devenir
propriétaires de leur logement
le but d'un jeune qui commence dans la
vie c'est pas simplement d'avoir un chez
m celle est propriétaire de son logement
il faut avoir de l'ambition madame royal
l'ambition c'est de faire de la france
une france de propriétaires
parce que qu'est ce qui se passe dans
les logements sociaux aujourd'hui comme
on n'arrive pas à être propriétaire
parce que c'est trop cher on reste dans
son hlm et le taux de rotation n'est pas
suffisant et ceux qui doivent avoir un
hlm n'arrive par la voix puisqu'il n'y a
pas ce taux de rotation mon engagement
c'est un engagement en faveur de la
propriété enfin dernier mot qui est un
point de désaccord certainement entre
nous moi je considère quand on a
travaillé toute sa vie il n'y a rien de
plus beau le plus utile que de laisser à
ses enfants le fruit d'une vie de
travail eh bien je propose que pour
toutes les successions petite ou moyenne
on supprime les droits de succession et
les droits de donation parce que je
crois à la famille je crois beaucoup à
la famille et parce que je crois au
travail et je ne vois pas au nom de quoi
quand on a travaillé toute sa vie payer
ses impôts on doit en plus payer
j'ajoute un dernier mot qui est un
véritable scandale lorsqu'il ya un mari
indélicat fait une fraude fiscale
la femme est responsable solidairement
de la dette fiscale du mari lorsque dans
le même couple mari décède
la femme doit payer des droits de
succession sur les biens communs du
couple deux poids deux mesures je
rétablirai cette injustice ségolène
royal est ce qu'on peut terminer à la
fois que sur l'environnement s'ils
voulaient revenir dans l'instant sur les
logements mais aussi sur l'environnement
l'engagement nucléaire l'engagement à
l'égard du pacte de nicolas hulot je
pense que le défi planétaire est l'un
des défis les plus importants que nous
avons à relever aujourd'hui je crois que
le réchauffement planétaire
conduira même aux conflits de demain à
l'échelle de la planète c'est-à-dire à
la recherche de l'eau potable on voit
aujourd'hui des déplacements de
population dans les pays les plus
pauvres et dans les pays les plus chauds
de populations qui sont à la recherche
de la survie et donc il y va y avoir une
montée des tensions si l'on ne résout
pas sérieusement cette question du
réchauffement planétaire et dans ce
domaine il y a eu beaucoup de discours
est très peu d'actes aujourd'hui la
france est très mal notée sur l'ensemble
des pays européens par rapport au peu
d'efforts qui ont été faits et j'entends
faire de la france le pays de
l'excellence écologique d'ailleurs nos
projets ont été notés par le collectif
d'associations indépendantes
le projet que je présente a reçu une
note de ces survint le vôtre de 8 sur 20
et je pense en effet qu'il faut que la
france se remette à niveau je les
exprime est déjà tout à l'heure je crois
que c'est à la fois des gestes c'est
individuel de chacun et notamment sur
les économies d'énergie sur les
économies d'eau sur une modification
profonde des structures des aides à
l'agriculture pour que l'agriculture
durable soit davantage si ce n'est au
moins autant aidés que l'agriculture
intensive que celle qui irriguent je
crois qu'il y à des filières de
développement industriel à développer le
véhicule propre à mettre en mouvement et
je souhaite que les industries
automobile française au lieu de
licencier comme elles le font
aujourd'hui mettent leurs laboratoires
de recherche en commun pour mettre au
point le véhicule propre qui demain
enfin on est en effet se verra ouvrir un
marché mondial et je regrette clio le
jury et les recettes du côté de monsieur
chevènement du côté des verts message
que vous confirmer le choix nucléaire
savez vous quelle est la part du
nucléaire dans la consommation
d'électricité en france oui mais est-ce
que vous le confirmer le choix quelle
est cette part ne croit nous avons
madame grâce au nucléaire une
indépendance sur l'électricité de
l'offre aux histoires de la moitié
défendez le nucléaire mais within york
la parano clair à la norme de que non
combien j'admire la moitié de notre
électricité qui est d'origine nucléaire
de 17% seulement que dit cette somme est
censée seulement de l'électricité
d'origine nucléaire madame sur l'état
exact de façon toute la saveur mais si
c'est ça bien ce que je nomme adam donc
ce que je veux pas mais c'est un choix
majeur est ce qu'on continue le choix du
nucléaire ou est-ce qu'on arrête
on augmente la part des énergies
renouvelables est ce qu'on consomme
l'endroit de l'unc l'armée du jour au
lendemain on ne va pas fermer les
centrales nucléaires confirmé enchères
en revanche non je suspends le prd que
je suis et c'est à dire un suspendait
les nouvelles centrales c'était vous
prolonger le père n'est pas une nouvelle
une centrale bien sûr d'aimer vous
mélangez ici mais ce père est un
prototype
le père est le prototype de quelle
génération n'est pas un prototype c'est
la quatrième génération non 3e générale
en de le vendre à la finlande madame le
il faut que les français comprennent il
faut que les français comprennent les
centrales nucléaires classiques ont une
durée de vie cette durée de vie alors
les experts discutent est ce que ces
trente ans est ce que ces 50 ans pour le
chapeau de couverture nous avons été
obligé de déclencher les centrales de la
quatrième génération
c'est le processus ppr qui a été acheté
c'est la 3ème général la finlande non à
la fin nous construisent aurait en
france entre le moment où j'ai signé au
pm et le moment où la première centrale
s'ouvrira il faut 7 en 7 ans si vous
revenez sur le choix de p r madame ça
veut dire que vous serez obligé pour
respectez votre parole de garder le même
pourcentage du nucléaire de faire
fonctionner les vieilles centrales plus
longtemps cela veut dire que vous
prendriez la responsabilité de faire
fonctionner des vieilles centrales plus
longtemps par refus du choix du progrès
qui sont les centrales de la dernière
génération c'est pas très raisonnable
sur six ordinateurs quand même très
approximative vous permettez bien sûr
vous avez une approche très
approximatives sur un sujet quand même
extrêmement technique et mais en même
temps extrêmement grave parce qu'il
s'agit de l'énergie nucléaire donc vous
venez de dire une série d'erreurs ça
peut arriver mais il faudra que vous
rêviez un peu votre sujet car il ne
s'agit pas de la 4e et de la 3e
génération que la finlande a déjà un
prototype est que justement la question
est de savoir s'il n'est pas plus
intelligent de coopérer entre différents
pays et de passer tout de suite à un
investissement sur la quatrième
génération
premier point c'est pour ça que je
réouvrirait le débat public sur
l'énergie au parlement mais aussi avec
les citoyens venus en six lots par mais
non si les chiffres ne m'interrompez je
vous écris ce n'est pas aux patients au
moment où j'ai signé au p r est la
position des finlandais consistait
d'ailleurs à nous dire madame permettait
pas de vous dire je connais le dossier
c'est bien beau que vous nous demandiez
ce prototype mais vous les français
est-ce que vous allez le prendre
j'aimerais que vous m'expliquiez madame
comment areva pourra construire le p r
en finlande avec vous présidente de la
république qui expliquerait au
finlandais que la fidèle au prc bien
pour eux mais qu'en france on va
continuer à réfléchir très tôt n'est
peut-être pas le dossier madame mais je
suis assez cohérent non c'est tout à
fait incohérent pourquoi c'est tout à
fait incohérent pourquoi construire deux
prototypes pourquoi construire deux
prototypes il y as eu lieu en finlande
il serait peut-être sans doute beaucoup
plus intelligent d'investir déjà dans la
quatrième génération
pourquoi parce qu'on sait très bien que
l'uranium dans quelques années va
disparaître il y aura une pénurie
d'uranium donc il y aura une pénurie du
combustible d'uranium les spécialistes
pour l'uranium disent que les ressources
connues si entre 60 et 70 ans oui et les
ressources prévisibles c'est jusqu'à
deux siècles et demi compte tenu des
progrès de la recherche mais tout dépend
du nombre de centrales il s'engouffrait
dans les mandats tollé dans votre
majorité contre les verts qui ne veulent
pas de nucléaire et les communistes qui
veulent le nucléaire qu'est-ce que vous
choisirez si vous êtes président ray
simple je choisi de maintenir le
nucléaire mais d'augmenter la part des
énergies renouvelables dans la
production d'enr dans le bouquet
énergétique et deuxièmement je regarde
avec beaucoup plus d'attention que cela
n'a été fait ou nous nous devons
investir les fonds publics pour préparer
l'énergie de demain car ce qui est
prometteur aujourd'hui au moment où la
question des déchets nucléaires n'a pas
été résolu c'est sans doute d'investir
dans le recyclage des déchets nucléaires
qui pourrait peut-être devenir justement
demain le nouveau combustible avec les
restes d'uranium le nouveau combustible
qui permettra justement de passer ce cap
de la pénurie d'uranium que je propose
et je pense en effet que les
technologies doivent avancer mais qu'on
ne peut pas aller vers le tout nucléaire
au contraire il faut diversifier le
bouquet énergétique et c'est ce que je
propose et c'est sans doute la raison
pour laquelle mon projet relatives à
l'écologie à l'environnement a été si
largement plébiscité par des
associations indépendantes
en association notamment un bruit à
l'autre indépendante grand cimefroides
elle est dépendante moi je ne suis pas
pour le tout nucléaire mais je dis qu'il
n'est pas raisonnable de dire on va
poursuivre le nucléaire mais on n'arrête
le progrès dans le nucléaire c'est pas
possible bien sûr qu'il faut développer
les énergies de substitution je pense
notamment nos départements et
territoires d'outre-mer ou le solaire
l'éolien la biomasse peut faire quelque
chose d'extraordinaire je crois que
c'est d'ailleurs une opportunité pour
les départements et territoires
d'outre-mer considérable je pense qu à
la réunion par exemple on peut leur
donner l'indépendance énergétique en
investissement massivement dans la
biomasse mais refusait le développement
des nouvelles filières nucléaires je
pense que si tu meurs comme on a la
chance d'être à peu près à trois quarts
d'heure de temps de parole l'un et
l'autre on va passer un autre chapitre
très important évidemment l'éducation la
famille on commence par vous si vous
rirez nicolas sarkozy qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour que chaque enfant est un
accès égal à la chance égale à l'école
dans sa famille un accès égal à la
culture et à kout à servir aussi l'école
aujourd'hui tout d'abord je crois qu'il
faut que nous soyons assez raisonnable
pour dire que le problème de l'école si
pas qu'un problème de moyens d'argent
une structure c'est aussi un problème de
programmes d'éducation scolaire et que
nous débattions de qu'est ce que nous
voulons faire de l'école qu'est ce
qu'elle est l'école que nous voulons moi
je veux une école du respect de
l'autorité de l'exigence du mérite ou
les enfants des familles modestes accès
de grands auteurs et/ou comme jules
ferry on a de l'ambition pour les
enfants une école qui transmet un savoir
une école qui a pas peur d'enseigner le
civisme une école qui transmet une
morale commune une école où les maîtres
sont respectées ou lorsque le maître en
dans la classe les élèves se lèvent en
signe de respect une école où chacun
sera reçu avec le soin d'un parcours
adaptés à ces problèmes je crois aux
limites du collège unique une école on
va répondre au malaise formidable des
enseignants qui ne sont pas assez payés
qu'ils ne sont pas assez récompensé une
école où pourra laisser ses enfants à
l'étude du soir sur la base du
volontariat pour qu'il rentre à la
maison les devoirs faits je propose une
révolution pour toutes les femmes de
france c'est que tous les enfants si je
suis élu président de la république
pourront au collège et au lycée tous les
jeunes restés en études surveillées
après la fin des cours pour rentrer à la
maison avec les devoirs faits il ya
beaucoup de femmes qui travaillent
beaucoup de femmes qui peuvent pas être
là quand les enfants rentrent de l'école
beaucoup de femmes qui seraient très
heureux que les enfants aient fait leur
devoir et leur travail à l'école
j'ajoute que ça permettrait de résoudre
le problème du pouvoir d'achat des
enseignants car c'est leur permettrait
de faire ses études encadrées là aussi
sur la base du volontariat pour être
davantage
rémunérés je souhaite également qu'on
puisse avoir le choix de l'école de 100
enfants
que nous ne soyons pas le seul pays où
on n'a pas le droit de choisir l'école
de son enfant
je souhaite qu'on donne davantage
d'autonomie aux établissements en
fonction des conditions sociales des
conditions géographiques des conditions
culturelles qu'on puisse adapter un
petit peu le programme qui est enseignée
aux enfants qu'on mette de la liberté
pédagogique je souhaite qu'on fasse
confiance aux enseignants maintenant un
enseignant est noté sur sa capacité à
appliquer la dernière circulaire du
dernier ministre je souhaite qu'il soit
jugé sur sa capacité à apprendre à lire
écrire et compter à ses enfants enfin
dernier point je souhaite pour
l'éducation nationale une nouvelle
pratique de l'évaluation c'est quand on
inscrit son enfant dans une école on
doit savoir quels sont les résultats de
cette école qu'est ce qui se passe
comment ça fonctionne quels sont les
résultats obtenus et quelles sont les
chances pour notre enfant de réussir
ségolène royal je crois qu'il nous faut
un nouveau pacte éducatif
dans l'école de la république il faut
que l'école garantissez tienne sa
promesse égalitaire aujourd'hui à
beaucoup de souffrance il ya beaucoup de
souffrance parce que les enseignants
veulent une reconnaissance de la société
de la difficulté de leur métier de la
revalorisation de leur travail
il y à la souffrance parce que la
violence scolaire a augmenté je lui ai
dit tout à l'heure elle a augmenté parce
que beaucoup d'emplois ont été supprimés
au cours de ces dernières années plus de
cent mille emplois ont été supprimés en
cinq ans dans le système scolaire faux
et en particulier tous les emplois
jeunes il y avait cinquante mille
emplois jeunes dans l'école qui ont été
supprimés et ces jeunes jouer un rôle
très important savez pour vous ça fait
chaud chiffres vous savez c'est parce
que jeune joueur je les ai pas
interrompu j'aimerais donc c'est juste
la précision je ne sais pas ce que les
personnels tos ont été transférés du
budget du ministère de l'éducation
nationale au budget des régions avec les
financements c'est pour ça que madame
royal 10 qui a eu tant d'emplois ils
n'ont pas été supprimés au contraire des
post hausse qui ont été créés mais au
lieu d'être
émerger e au budget de l'état c'est
maintenant dans le budget des régions
dont côté dit que c'était supprimés
c'est faux ça a été transféré de l'état
aux régions avec les financements qui
vont avec je ne vous parle pas de tous
je vous parle dans jeux éducatifs pour
la nation et l'enjeu éducatif pour la
nation pour la présidente de la
république que je serais peut-être je
l'espère sera mon ange principal je
remettrai l'éducation au coeur de tout
et en avant de tout parce que c'est là
que la république tient la maison france
est d'abord je veux que tous les enfants
sortent de l'école avec un bagage
aujourd'hui ils sont cent cinquante
mille à sortir de l'école sans
qualification et cela je veux y mettre
fin en aidant les enfants dès le plus
jeune âge c'est pourquoi je m en place
d'abord un service public de la petite
enfance avant l'âge de 3 ans ensuite
l'école sera rendue obligatoire à partir
de l'âge de trois ans je remettrai les
emplois jeunes dans le système scolaire
parce que je veut éradiquer la violence
de l'école et aux abords des
établissements scolaires je veux enfin
que les élèves puissent avoir un soutien
scolaire individualisé au moment où ils
en ont le plus besoin que ce soit par
les enseignants s'ils sont volontaires
que ce soit par les aides éducateurs qui
seront là que ce soit par un nouveau
métier de répétiteur que je créerai bref
je veux que la présence humaine et la
présence d'adultes se renforce dans les
écoles je veux ensuite qu'il y ait de
l'égalité entre les différents
établissements scolaires je ne veux pas
je ne veux plus que certains enfants
soient programmés pour échouer pour
échouer et d'autres pour réussir alors
je veux renforcer les moyens dans les
zones d'éducation prioritaires mais
aussi les pots les moyens pour les
élèves en difficulté qui ne sont pas
dans les zones d'éducation prioritaire
et c'est pourquoi la dynamique et le
principe du soutien individuel je crois
que l'école que la france aujourd'hui
peut se payer cela peut se payer le
soutien individuel parce qu'il n'ya pas
plus grande inégalité entre les enfants
qui peuvent se faire aider par leurs
parents qui ont cette chance et ceux qui
ne peuvent pas se faire aider en retour
à la maison et qui reviennent le matin
avec la peur au ventre parce qu'ils
n'ont pas fait leurs devoirs et leurs
leçons et bien tous ces enfants là
auront dès la rentrée prochaine le
soutien scolaire gratuit et
individualisé et les étudiants qui
auront des bourses
seront invités justement a donné aussi
ce soutien scolaire aux élèves parce que
je veux créer une société de la
solidarité ou ceux qui ont la chance de
faire des études supérieures peuvent
apporter à ceux qui n'ont pas cette
chance enfin je veux renforcer
l'autonomie des établissements j'ai été
ministre de l'enseignement scolaire j'ai
vu qu'il y avait des réalisations
exceptionnelles qui a des réussites
extraordinaires y compris dans les
endroits les plus difficiles parce qu'on
a remis notamment de la culture il y à
une pénurie de culture à l'école je veux
que la culture reviennent dans tous les
établissements scolaires de l'école
primaire jusqu'au baccalauréat car
souvent quand un élève échoue échoue
dans la lecture et dans l'écriture eh
bien il peut réussir grâce au théâtre
grâce à l'informatique grâce justement à
ces contournements du système scolaire
trop rigide et toutes les expériences
pédagogiques qui réussissent dans les
établissements scolaires parce qu'il ya
des enseignants qui sont formidables qui
sont les nouveaux usages de la
république dans ces quartiers difficiles
il qu'ils pourront demain choisir leurs
équipes qui pourront expérimenter leurs
méthodes pédagogiques qui seront libres
pour cela et en contrepartie ils
pourront évaluer leurs résultats et en
contrepartie ils auront des dotations
horaires pour leur permettre le travail
en équipe car ce que demandent les
enseignants difficulté c'est de pouvoir
faire le travail en équipe enfin je veux
rapprocher les familles et l'école car
je crois que c'est dans un partenariat
étroit et j'avais créé quand j'étais
ministre l'enseignement scolaire la
semaine des parents à l'école et tous
les établissements scolaires en zones
difficiles qui ont réussi cette
articulation entre la famille et l'école
où l'enfant n'entend pas dans la famille
critiqué l'école et n'entend pas à
l'école dévaloriser sa famille à ce
moment là il est restructurée dans une
autorité moi je suis pour une autorité
juste l'autorité parentale
l'autorité à l'école mais aussi la
volonté de faire réussir tous les élèves
dans leur diversité voilà le défi que je
relèverai demain et en particulier dans
les quartiers dans les quartiers
difficiles là où rien n'a été résolu là
où les subventions n'ont pas été rendus
aux associations la ou des classes vont
fermer encore à la prochaine rentrée
parce que 5000 postes d'anciennes ans
vient d'être supprimée et moi je les
rendrai dès cet été ses postes
d'enseignants ces 5000 postes la rentrée
scolaire avec moi se fera à moyens
identiques à ceux de la fin de l'année
scolaire et nous mettrons ces emplois
d'enseignants là où il y en a le plus
besoin mais la revendication éducative
dans les quartiers populaires elle est
considérable c'est là qu'est la chance
des jeunes de demain eh bien ma priorité
sera de faire deux choses très concrètes
d'abord de diviser les gros collège je
ne veux plus qu'un seul collège et plus
de 600 élèves parce que c'est comme ça
qu'un chef d'établissement connaît
individuellement ses élèves et fait
reculer la violence dans les
établissements scolaires et deuxièmement
je ne veux pas plus de 17 élèves par
classe parce que c'est comme cela aussi
que l'on peut travailler 1 10 du helmand
avec les élèves mais voilà le défi
scolaire que je relèverai et c'est
pourquoi je ne veux pas diminuer le
nombre d'enseignants mais au contraire
créer un métier nouveau un métier
d'accompagnant nouveau qui fera la fois
le soutien scolaire qui épaulera les
enseignants qui le souhaitent et qui
réglera le problème de la violence se
lançant dans l'école ni aux abords de
l'école et ensuite alors il ya les rend
moins il ya des points d'accord d'abord
le soutien individuel
c'est ce que j'appelais tout à l'heure
les limites du collège unique c'est vrai
tous nos enfants sont différents et des
enfants qui ont des difficultés ça sert
à rien de les faire doubler dans les
mêmes conditions il faut du soutien
individuel plus de culture à l'école
plus d'enseignements artistiques oui je
suis tout à fait d'accord si vous me
permettez j'ajouterai plus de sport ci
ne faut pas opposer l'un à l'autre mais
nos enfants ont besoin de davantage
d'enseignements artistiques et de
davantage de sport la place des familles
et les centrales mais je souhaite des
familles qui signe le règlement
intérieur et qui le respectent par
ailleurs je veux le dire je pense que
les familles c'est pas simplement un
lieu ou une adresse exacte de droit edd
allocations quand il ya des familles
défaillante je souhaite que les
allocations familiales puis cette mise
sous tutelle c'est déjà prévu non mais
même moi je souhaite que ça soit fait
parce que tout ça est payé avec l'argent
de ceux qui travaillent lorsqu'une
famille à des difficultés il faut
l'aider il faut la prendre par la main
mais lorsqu'une famille se sert des
allocations familiales pour autre chose
que pour éduquer les enfants par exemple
je veux lutter contre l'absentéisme
scolaire qui est un drame en donnant des
moyens au maire pour lutter contre cet
absentéisme scolaire qui est une
question absolument essentiel faut
responsabiliser les familles encore une
fois madame royal dans la république a
pas que des droits il ya aussi des deux
ans et déjà prévu que je regrette de
choses on n'a pas parlé de la formation
technique et de l'apprentissage qui est
essentiel et je souhaite notamment que
les filières professionnelles puissent
obtenir les mêmes diplômes que les
filières générales comprenez moi je
souhaite qu'on puisse devenir ingénieur
soit par le biais de la filière générale
le bac et cetera soit pas le biais de la
filière technique pour qu'on se dise pas
qu'une famille qui aimait ses enfants
dans les filières techniques soient
condamnés même si l'enfant le jeune
réussissent bien à ne pas avoir le
diplôme supérieur qu'il aurait pu avoir
dans l'enseignement général
je lui ai également mettre le paquet sur
l'apprentissage qui est un élément
essentiel alors un point de divergence
de service public de la petite enfance
dans ta sujet considérable il ya près de
deux millions d'enfants qui doivent
avoir une place en crèche chacun
comprend bien qu on pourrait pas de
créer deux millions de places en crèche
je crois que nos 350 milles ou quelque
chose comme ça moi ce que je souhaite
c'est que toutes les femmes et d'une
solution pour la garde de leurs enfants
c'est la raison pour laquelle monsieur
engager sur quelque chose de très
ambitieux qui est le droit opposable à
la garde d'enfant je dis aux françaises
qu'à la fin de mon quinquennat
chacun pourra faire valoir devant les
tribunaux le droit de trouver une place
pour garder son enfant mais pour moi
c'est pas simplement la crise public ça
peut être la crèche associative
ça peut être la crèche d'entreprise ça
peut être l'emploi la personne l'emploi
domicile je souhaite d'ailleurs qu'on
puisse déduire de ses impôts et salaires
et les cotisations sociales qu'on paye
sur un emploi à domicile comme
extraordinaire lorsqu'une société
embauche quelqu'un et paypal yes sur le
salaire de la personne qui l emploi je
vois pas pourquoi la famille devrait
payer un impôt sur le salaire et les
charges qu'elle déclare voilà les
différences qu'il peut y avoir entre
nous sur cette question non il faut
évidemment parler quand même
qu'elles n'auront pas besoin d'aller
devant les tribunaux
quelle drôle de société mais qu'elles
ont le service public de la petite
enfance sous toutes ses formes ça peut
être vous rendez vous secret 2 millions
soyez sérieux non mais c'est souvent
aller devant le tribunal pour demander
une place de crèche c'est soyez service
passe abbas et ses associés donc vous
nous proposez aller devant les tribunaux
pour demander une place en crèche adam
ça n'est pas ma conception de la société
et les fermes ont autre chose à faire
que les devant le tribunal il faut me le
faut faire les choses en politique
d'amitié faire les choses vous n'avez
c'est pas joli de la méprise en dessous
de ce palier je connais vos techniques
allemands n'ont été que vous êtes gênés
où vous vous la mettez une poser en
victime de la fusion entre t méprisant
et vous cesserez et estime qu'on
s'entend c'est une question de bon sens
mieux à leurs moyens de les y envoyer
essayé généraux de respect pour vous
pour vous laisser aller dans le mépris
les droits opposables c'est quelque
chose de très important ce site qui
permettra de passer de la république des
droits virtuel à la république des
droits réels et la
serbie mais non c'était moi qui avais la
parole j'ai préfère l'action politique
et rien dire excusez choses sont des
mots plutôt que les français en attente
étaient normaux moi je m'engage je sais
pas moi non pas du tout parce que
s'infligent envoyé devant les tribunaux
qui sont déjà débordés et bien je vais
déjà bien d'autres je vais prendre un
autre sera sérieux d'extrême ça c'est
pas sérieux c'est nécessaire je place en
crèche c'est dans les structures
actuelles dire des choses comme ça je
vais prendre un exemple qui va peut-être
vous toucher et vous avez mieux
comprendre la pensée la sphère des
enfants handicapés dans les écoles pour
moi je considère qu'il est scandaleux
qu'un enfant ayant un handicap ne puisse
pas être scolarisés dans une école entre
guillemets normal c'est important pour
l'enfant ayant un handicap mais c'est
encore plus important pour nous autres
enfants qui n'ont pas de handicap et qui
au contact de cet enfant différent
apprendront que la différence est une
richesse
dans les démocraties du nord de l'europe
cent pour cent des enfants ayant un
handicap sont scolarisés en ciment en
milieu scolaire disons classique en
france c'est 40 % je veux créer un droit
opposable ça veut dire quoi qu une
famille au bout de cinq ans à qui on
refuserait une famille à un enfant
handicapé une place dans une école
pourrait aller devant le tribunal en
disant écoutez la république m'a promis
un droit un homme politique s'est engagé
il n'a pas tenu sa promesse qu'est-ce
qui se passe et bien moi je veux en
finir avec ces discours creux pas le
vaudou peut être désagréable ses
promesses incantatoire cette grande
braderie au moment de l'élection on rase
gratis on promet tout et quand on sait
pas promettre on promet une discussion
je veux m'engager sur des résultats sur
du concret
je veux dire à toutes les familles ayant
rencontré le drame de handicap que si je
suis élu président de la république je
ferais une place à chacun des enfants
dans nos écoles que je donnerai les
moyens écoles pour les accueillir et que
la preuve de ma bonne foi et la
certitude de la réalisation de cette
promesse ça sera le droit opposable et
la capacité d'aller devant un tribunal
pour faire valoir ses droits vous voyez
madame ceni ridicule ni accessoire c'est
peut-être même ce qui fait la différence
entre la vieille politique et la
politique non vérifié tous les bus le
summum de l'immoralité politique
je suis scandalisée de ce que je viens
d'entendre parce que jouer avec le
handicap comme vous venez de le faire
est proprement scandaleux pourquoi
lorsque j'étais ministre de
l'enseignement scolaire c'est moi qui ai
créé le plan en 10 cols qui a demandé à
toutes les écoles
d'accueillir tous les enfants handicapés
et pour cela j'avais créé parmi les
aides éducateurs que vous avez supprimé
7000 places 7000 postes d'éducateurs
d'auxiliaires d'intégration j'avais
doter toutes les associations de parents
d'enfants handicapés
des emplois liés à l'accompagnement et à
l'eau et aux auxiliaires d'intégration
dans les établissements scolaires et
c'est votre gouvernement
qui a supprimé non seulement le plan dix
cols tient supprimer les aides
éducateurs et qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
moins d'un enfant sur deux qui étaient
accueillis il y a cinq ans dans l'école
de la république ne le sont plus
aujourd'hui et vous le savez
parfaitement et je trouve que la façon
dont vous venez de nous décrire comme ça
la larme à l'oeil le droit des enfants
handicapés d'intégrer à l'école alors
que les associations de parents
handicapés en fait des démarches
désespérée auprès de votre gouvernement
pour réclamer la restitution des emplois
pour faire en sorte que leurs enfants
soient à nouveau accueillis à l'école y
compris les enfants en situation de
handicap mental à l'école maternelle ou
avec moi tous les enfants handicapés
mentaux étaient accueillis à l'école
maternelle
dès lors que les parents le demander
alors laissez de côté vos tribunaux les
démarches des parents qui en ont assez
des ja de leurs souffrances et d'avoir
vu leurs enfants ne pas pouvoir est
inscrit au lors des rentrées scolaires
pendant lesquelles vous étiez au
gouvernement laissez cela de côté parce
que la façon là dont vous venez faire de
l'immoralité politique par rapport à une
politique qui a été détruite et à
laquelle je tenais particulièrement
parce que je sais à quel point cela
soulager les parents devant leurs
enfants accueillis à l'école et c'est
vous qui avez cassé cette politique là
et aujourd'hui vous venez de promettre
comme ça en disant par an vous allez
aller devant les tribunaux non monsieur
sarkozy tout n'est pas possible dans la
vie politique tout n'est pas possible ce
discours cet écart entre le discours et
des seins et les actes surtout lorsqu'il
s'agit d'enfants handicapés n'est pas
acceptable et je suis très en colère et
les parents et les familles qui vise en
effet les parents non j'ai eu le gars ne
l'avons pas du doigt si l'index non
parce que franchement non je voudrais
pas je mens je ne calmerait pas je ne
calmeront les pages il en a que les fous
et non pas quand il y à des injustices
il ya des colères qui sont parfaitement
saine parce qu'elles correspondent à la
souffrance des gens ce que vous viendrez
colère dieu j'aurais même quand je serai
présidente de la république cela ce que
je sais parce que je sais pas ce que je
sais les efforts qu'ont fait les
familles qu'on fait les écoles pour
accueillir ces enfants qui aujourd'hui
on ne le sont plus
voilà je ne laisserai pas de
l'immoralité du discours politique
reprendre le dessus je ne je ne sais pas
pourquoi madame royal d'habitude calme a
perdu ses nerfs non jeûneurs je suis en
colère sachant qu'un pareil fin de
mépris monsieur a choisi j'ai aucun de
mes prix que je n'ai pas perdu manière
je suis en colère sur le chemin de
répondre vous permettez et il ya des cas
ce n est très utile je ne sais pas
pourquoi madame royal s'énerve et je ne
m'énerve pas très bien ce que ça doit
être quand vous êtes énervé alors je ne
suis jamais énervé je me suis beaucoup
de sang froid à porte très bien écoutez
vous venez de le perdre annoncés n'ont
justement pas je suis en colère fois on
a juste madame royal mensonges aux
employé le mot immoral c'est un mot fort
madame royal se permet d'employer ce mot
parce que j'ai dit que je souhaitais que
tous les enfants ayant un handicap
soient scolarisés au milieu scolaire
entre guillemets normal
madame royal a qualifié mon propos de
larme à l'oeil sous entendant par là que
la sincérité [ __ ] de son côté que de
mon côté il devait y avoir que du
mensonge c'est même le terme quels
employés c'est pas une façon de
respecter son concurrent ou un autre
candidat je me serais jamais permis
l'enfant dit je ne serais jamais permis
madame de parler de vous comme cela puis
je vous dire autre chose parce que moi
je n'y ai parlé je ne mens pas et je ne
prétends pas faire ce que j'ai détruit
avant madame
je ne pense pas que vous élevez la
dignité du débat politique dans votre
réseau la question du handicap j'ajoute
que si je n'avais pas moi même par
conviction parler de la question de la
scolarisation des enfants handicapés
ça faisait une heure et demi que nous
débattions on en avait pas parlé donc
j'ai le droit de parler du handicap
ce n'est pas le monopole qui est le
vôtre j'ai le droit d'être sincère dans
mon engagement est d'être bouleversée
par la situation d'enfants qui aimerait
être scolarisés je ne mets pas en cause
votre sincérité madame ne mettez pas en
cause la moralité c'est vraiment avec sa
madame la dignité du débat politique
sera préservée mais au moins ça une
utilité madame c'est que vous mettez
bien facilement en colère vous sortez de
vos gonds avec beaucoup de facilité par
aman président de la république c'est
quelqu'un qui a des responsabilités
lourdes très lourdes
il est 23h est-ce qu'on peut passer à un
autre sujet qui est le sujet de l'europe
qui est un sujet important aussi
l'europe qui est en panne aujourd'hui
deux ans après l'échec du référendum en
france et donnez votre petite pichenette
je ne suis pas sorti de mes gonds vous
permettez parce que moi aussi j'ai
l'intention de me faire respecter je ne
suis pas sorti de mes gonds je crois que
ce qui nous différencie c'est une vision
de la morale politique et je pense qu'il
faut que les discours soient cohérents
avec les actes et qui quand il ya un tel
écart on ne peut pas avoir détruit
l'accueil des enfants handicapés les
folles madame non ça il ya trois fois
plus d'enfants school handicapés
scolarisés aujourd'hui sur d'autres
avraiment dans ce n'est pas fou me
connais de réfléchir il avait vraiment
non madone les associations ont protesté
auprès de vous ce que vous avez supprimé
je n'ai jamais été bizuté bien sûr
nationale et don de vous de votre
gouvernement de veauche mon gouvernement
je m'étais premier ministre non plus
donc voilà ne soyez pas condescendant
mais je ne suis pas prêt tout savez je
vous entends des colères saines comme
cela par rapport aux injustices ou par
rapport à un discours politique qui ne
correspond pas aux actes mais on peut
aller bien c'est votre que vient sans
doute très dévote comptera dix neuvième
morale et de menteurs oui je vois pas ce
que ça de 5,6 et d'utile je l'avais
l'addition sera l'élément terme cela
c'est que la vision sectaire de la
gauche
toute personne qui ne pensent pas
exactement comme vous je connais
forcément un email ou un succès pas du
tout au contraire que ça
va revenir dans le
jeu terminé l'étude et enchaîne ensuite
sur les actions opérer assure parce que
je crois que ce débat est très important
c'est toute une conception de la vie
politique et de la responsabilité
politique qui est là si on n'est
responsable de rien si on a des comptes
à rendre jamais sur ses actes politiques
mais comment voulez vous que les
citoyens se doit ce que question de
conception et la pole de l'action
politique il faut se rendre jusqu'à
messieurs je le connais ce dont je parle
je lisais des mots qui ne sont pas des
mots qui blessent mais les mots ne
voulions pas ce sont les actions qui
blesse on emploie des mots qui blessent
on divise son possède blessé alors qu'il
faut leur assemblée vous êtes donc aux
mots puis vous savez très bien bonne
nouvelle j'aime bien je vais vous dire
quelque chose je vais bien je vous en
veux pas parce que ça peut arriver à
tout le monde de s'énerver non
je me révolte sur les caps et garder
mathieu passé de révolte un tacle moyens
de poser que des questions mais leur
obtenant alors
la machine européenne
l'un ou l'autre élu demain comment
relancer vous un peu la construction
européenne qui est en panne notamment
après le choix français du non au
référendum je veux que la france
revienne à la table de l'europe
il ya eu 7 ce référendum et je crois
pouvoir rassembler à la fois des
responsables politiques qui ont voté non
à la constitution d'autres qui ont voté
oui à la constitution et donc je
respecte les français dans leur vote
beaucoup de france et d'ailleurs ont
voté non parmi les catégories populaires
parce qu'ils ont estimé que l'europe
était un espace qui ne les protège et
pas assez et en particulier contre les
délocalisations ou contre le chômage ou
contre les bas salaires alors je veux
relancer l'europe par la preuve et je
veux à nouveau consulter les français
par référendum le moment venu pour que
ce référendum soit réussie c'est à dire
pour qu'un nouveau traité entre en
application il va falloir que l'europe
fasse ses preuves et je m'en suis
entretenu avec plusieurs dirigeants
européens et c'est pourquoi je veux
relancer l'europe de l'investissement de
la recherche de l'environnement et
surtout faire la preuve que l'europe
peut réussir la bataille contre le
chômage que l'europe peut réussir à se
protéger des délocalisations
que l'europe peut réussir à avancer vers
un protocole social sur lequel jacques
delors à travailler parce que si l'on
veut éviter les délocalisations au sein
de l'europe alors il faut travailler à
l'élévation des niveaux de vie vers le
haut et pas des compétitions vers les
pays à bas salaires s'ils n'ont en effet
les français n'auront pas confiance dans
cette europe et moi je crois que c'est
possible je crois qu'avec un protocole
social qui dira que l'objectif de
l'europe c'est l'alignement vers le haut
de la situation des salariés de la
protection sociale des droits sociaux
des niveaux des salaires avec bien sur
l'effort qu'il faudra faire pour les
pays situés le plus à l'est de l'europe
pour qu'ils réussissent leur
développement économique comme l'ont
fait l'espagne et le portugal il faut
réussir la même aux avec les pays du
reste de l'europe pour que le niveau de
vie européen tire les pays
collectivement vers le haut alors je
pense oui que nous pourrons à nouveau
consulter les français et faire en sorte
que l'europe reviennent l'europe forte
la france forte dans une europe qui a
besoin de la france et d'une france qui
a besoin de l'europe ce sarkozy faisait
plus de trois minutes de retard bon
d'écouter alors pour être le plus précis
et le plus simple d'abord les fonctions
voté non à la constitution nous y
reviendrons pas quelle que soit la
qualité remarquable du travail de valéry
giscard d'estaing cette constitution
n'entrera pas en vigueur puisque les
français ont dit non premier point
deuxième fois je crois très important
d'arrêter la course en avant vers
l'élargissement tant qu'on n'a pas doter
l'europe de nouvelles institutions et je
pose très clairement la question de la
turquie si je suis président de la
république je m'opposerai à l'entrée de
la turquie dans l'union européenne
troisième élément il faut que l'europe
accepte l'idée de la préférence
communautaire
si on a fait l'europe c'est parce qu'on
la préfère et il faut qu'on arrête la
naïveté dans les négociations omc c'est
bien beau d'ouvrir nos marchés je suis
d'accord mais sur la base de la
réciprocité
et du même moment on ne peut pas ouvrir
nos marchés à des pays qui n'ouvre pas
les leurs troisième élément il faut
revenir sur la règle de l'unanimité qui
empêche par exemple une politique de
l'immigration commune la règle de
l'unanimité au titre du compromis de
luxembourg de 1962 ou nul pays ne peut
se voir imposer une règle oui mais la
règle de l'unanimité qui fait que pour
tout son avance il faut que tout le
monde soit d'accord non ce qui nous
permettrait d'avoir effectivement une
politique de l'énergie madame une
politique de l'immigration une politique
de la sécurité commune c'est la raison
pour laquelle je débloquerait la
situation en europe en proposant un
traité simplifié sur laquelle monsieur
zapatero
blair et madame merkel m'ont donné leur
accord qui permettra de doter l'europe
d'un président élu qui ne fait que cela
de modifier
les compositions de la commission et
d'un certain nombre de sujets et qui
fera de l'europe une protection pour les
français et non pas le cheval de troie
de la mondialisation prêter sans
référendum déçus puisque le référendum
c'est pour la constitution ceux qui
veulent faire un nouveau référendum
c'est qu'ils veulent faire passer la
constitution je veux pas d'une nouvelle
constitution puisque les français ont
dit non les français ont dit non à 55 %
va pas recommencer un référendum pour
leur dire quoi qu'on voit la nouvelle
constitution donc pour moi c'est clair
ils ont dit non ils ont dit non on doit
débloquer la situation en europe en
modifiant simplement les institutions
européennes sur la base donc on peut
faire pour que l'europe soit plus forte
face à des états unis qui d'ailleurs
souhaitent lente la turquie d'un
oui mais mais mais ceux qui souhaitent
l'entrée de la turquie en europe ce et
ceux qui ne croient pas l'europe
politique
puisque l' élargissement sans limites de
l'europe c'est la mort de l'europe
politique est de mon point de vue je
suis très clair d'ailleurs juste
j'aimerais savoir vous avez été à une
réunion de l'internationale socialiste
vous avez d'ailleurs été fort applaudis
mais je ne sais pas si vous avez lu la
déclaration l'internationale socialiste
elle était favorable à l'entrée de la
turquie en europe qu'est ce que madame
c'est votre position mais il ya un
processus qui est ouvert et vous le
savez très bien
le peuple français sera consultée par
référendum sur cette lancée à l'appel de
faire peur moi je pense qu'il faut faire
une pause donc le moment n'est pas venu
où jaillit de faire entrer la turquie
elle doit rendre les de toute façon
c'est une échéance si elle rend bien
dire aux turcs parce que à force de dire
c'est une chance les négociations
commencées en 1964 nous sommes en 2007
il est quand même venu le temps de dire
aux turcs est-ce qu'on en veut ou est ce
que l'on veut pas pour moi d'ailleurs
c'est pas une question de démocratie
c'est pas du tout une question de
musulmans ou d'islam cclat turquie c'est
l'asie mineure
c'est pas l'europe et donc il faut dire
clairement à ce grand peuple la turquie
qu'ils ont vocation à être le coeur de
l'union de la méditerranée mais pas le
coeur de l'union européenne
un processus a été engagé vous savez
fort bien avec l'accord de la france
donc la france doit tenir sa parole non
on ne peut pas comme ça décidé en
cellule changé c'est l'unanimité donc si
la turquie remparts on ne peut pas comme
ça change et un autre chef de l'état a
dit que les français seraient pour tout
élargissement supplémentaires consultés
par référendum donc les français seront
consultés dans l votre position ça nous
rassure qui pour l'instant
pour l'un c'est une pause sandwich et je
pense qu'il peut changer ça peut changer
puisque moi ce large à rolle puisque la
partage des données nonciature trio
sinon la parole mais un processus de
discussion qui est engagée la via un
processus de discussion d'engager la
discussion
quand on discute c'est pas
obligatoirement pour dire oui ou alors
dans ce cas là il faut progresser de
discussions mais vous venez cet
indicateur va changer c'est à dire que
vous pouvez changer d'avis et la turquie
peut rentrer en europe pas du tout il ya
des conditions qui sont posées donc s'il
turquie un moment rempli ces conditions
et si le peuple français dit oui
peut-être que d'ici là il y aura aussi
d'autres solutions il y aura des
associations prioritaire il ya des
courbes des coopérations renforcées je
ne crois pas que ce soit de bonne
politique comme ça de claquer la porte h
30 pêche et j'ai voulu parce qu'elle est
forces démocratiques aussi en mouvement
en turquie qui ont besoin d'être
construit qu'on nous explique si vous
saviez comme la cappadoce qui sont
européens vous aurez fait une seule
chose il est vous aurez renforcer
l'islamisme je pense qu'il faudrait sans
sable je pense que je responsable à
l'égard de l' équilibre du monde et
parler comme vous l'avez fait à
l'instant de la turquie je pense que ça
n'aide pas les forces démocratiques à
l'intérieur ou contre à l'intérieur de
la tu viens nous rencontrer les
résidents si l'europe se ferme alors que
je vous savez très bien que j'en veux
mettre en place des coopérations
privilégié que l'on peut voir comment
les choses évoluent à des joueurs de
toute façon ça ne se fait pas avant plus
d'une dizaine d'années et donc ne pas
utiliser main sujets comme ça de façon
aussi brutale mais pour un peuple
maroilles grand peuple il ya une
aspiration puisse rejoindre le rendant
donc ne faire ne manquez pas la porte
parce que je pense que c'est dangereux
au bon équilibre est tout le contraire
me donne depuis 40 ans on laisse à
croire à nos amis turcs à vous avez
raison c'est un grand pope et une grande
civilisation qu'ils ont leur place en
union européenne un pays laïque avec 40
ans qu'on le refuse à l'ailé grande
manifestation pour la laïcité à fait car
vient d'avoir lieu en turquie mais
madame et dont ce mouvement al ayam et
démocratique quand bien même c'est taper
laïque il est en asie mineure je
n'expliquerai pas aux écoliers français
que les frontières de l'europe sont avec
l'irak et la syrie et quand on aura fait
du kurdistan un problème européen n'aura
pas faire danser les choses et je ne
pense pas très calmement que la
stabilité du monde on va la renforcer en
tuant l'europe ceux qui sont les
adversaires de l'europe politique sont
pour l'élargissement sans fin de
l'europe parce que l'élargissement sans
fin de l'europe empêche la réalisation
de l'europe politique je suis pour
l'europe politique donc je préfère qu'on
dise aux turcs vous allez être associé à
l'europe on va faire un marché commun
avec vous mais vous ne serez pas membre
de l'union européenne pour une raison
très simple c'est que vous êtes en asie
mineure puisqu'on parle de l'équipe du
monde peut être un mot sur l'iran quand
même est-ce que pour vous c'est un pays
dangereux pour vous deux le pays n'est
pas dangereux ce sont les dirigeants de
ce pays qui sont extrêmement dangereux
et avec laquelle il faut être très ferme
pour refuser à toute force toutes
perspectives d'obtention pour eux du
nucléaire militaire
oui il ya longtemps que je me suis
exprimé sur cette question là même à une
époque où a prise de position avait été
contesté en effet il faut interdire
l'enrichissement de l'uranium a une
dimension industrielle
donc il faut aller au delà de
l'interdiction du nucléaire militaire je
pense qu'il faut faire plus qu'il faut
interdire l'enrichissement de l'uranium
y compris à des fins civiles
puisqu'aujourd'hui l'iran se refuse aux
inspections de l'agencé de vienne et
donc il faut être extrêmement ferme
puisqu'on sait très bien qu'à partir de
la maîtrise de la technologie de
l'enrichissement de l'uranium à des fins
civiles on peut ensuite passer à des
fins militaires moi je souhaite une
position beaucoup plus strictes que
celles que vous avez évoqué la sanction
croyais aux sanctions qui sont
actuellement appliquées ou est ce que
votre avis il faudra aller plus loin et
de quelle manière dont la politique des
sanctions doublée d'une politique
d'union de la communauté internationale
c'est la seule démarche crédible
aujourd'hui pour maîtriser un président
et un gouvernement iranien on peut
considérer que c'est le dossier le plus
sensible et plus dangereux aujourd'hui
dans les relations internationales
parlant d'un continent on méprise
beaucoup aux en tout cas qui souffrent
c'est l'afrique l'afrique et le darfour
est ce que votre politique changera par
rapport à celle de l'actuel chef de
l'état nicolas sarkozy ce qui se passe
au darfour c'est un scandale absolu le
fait que le gouvernement n'ait pas voulu
permettent les corridors humanitaires et
inadmissible il faut que les dirigeants
est en rendre compte devant un tribunal
pénal international deuxième élément il
ya 450 millions de jeunes africains qui
ont moins de 17 ans ils ne peuvent pas
espérer venir immigrés en europe la
question du développement de l'afrique
est une question majeure
que je traiterai dans le cadre
d'ailleurs d'union de la méditerranée et
troisième élément ça va de pair avec une
politique d'immigration choisie en
france avec la réforme de regroupement
familial
je n'autoriserai plus quelqu'un faire
venir sa famille s'il ne prouve pas
qu'il a un logement parce que faire
venir sa famille quand on n'a pas de
logement c'est pas possible qu'il n'a
pas de revenus de son travail et non pas
des allocations sociales parce qu à quoi
ça sert de faire venir sa famille
si on n'a pas de quoi la faire vivre et
je souhaite qu'ils apprennent les
membres de la famille qui vont rejoindre
le français avant de venir en france
ségolène royal sur l'immigration mais
bon sur le darfour en effet je pense que
la communauté internationale est
beaucoup trop binaire tu je pense que
des pressions doivent être faites sur la
chine y compris sur la menace de boycott
des jeux olympiques c'est justement je
suis favorable au boycott mais je pense
qu'il faut se poser la question pour que
ça bouge et pour mettre fin à ces
exactions verjon son trou à ces
exactions je suis favorable aux jeux
olympiques en chine d'ailleurs je
comprends pas la position de madame
royal qui est favorable au boycott pour
les jeux olympiques qui s'est rendu en
chine et qui revenu de chine en
félicitant la justice commerciale
chinoise donc si vous êtes favorable au
boycott pour les sportifs pourquoi vous
même n'avez vous pas boycotter votre
visite c'est quand même curieux de dire
aux autres n'allez pas en chine et vous
même d'y être allé le mouvement sportif
international c'est un mouvement de paix
de ces la jeunesse du monde est au
contraire les jeux olympiques à pékin
obligeront la société chinoise à
s'ouvrir comme on l'a toujours vu le
boycott en la matière c'est une très
mauvaise idée je suis allé en chine
parce que je pense que chaque français
doit aller en chine je suis allé en
chine pour voir les entreprises
françaises pour les encourager à
conquérir des marchés je suis allé en
chine pour rencontrer l'ensemble des
dirigeants chinois
parce qu'en effet il ya là des
opportunités à saisir et j'ai même
visité figurez-vous les installations
des jeux olympiques donc ne déformez pas
mes propos et je n'ai pas féliciter la
justice chinoise contrairement à ce qui
a été dit au contraire j'ai mis en garde
les entreprises françaises sur la
rapidité de la justice commerciale
chinoise en leur disant que la france
protégerait davantage les brevets
français en revanche j'ai fait des
démarches officielles pour la libération
d'avocats et de journalistes emprisonnés
et donc je ne me suis pas tu sur ces
sujets en allant en chine en revanche
quand je vois l'urgence du darfour et le
rôle que joue la chine dans cette partie
du monde parce que il ya simplement du
pétrole dans le sous sol si on renonce à
toute action alors on renonce à tout
également puisqu'il ya là justement ce
grand événement mondial qui doit
intervenir je suis convaincu que d'ici
plusieurs pays intervenez auprès de la
chine en dix ans c'est incompatible
d'organiser les jeux olympiques avec la
presse du monde entier qui sera là
l'opportunité en effet de développement
pour la chine et en même temps continuer
à fermer les yeux sur la question du
darfour je suis convaincu que s'il y
avait une démarche conjointe alors cela
pourrait bouger en afrique et moi je
suis pour l'action et pas pour les lois
sur l'immigration pour être sur
l'immigration je pense qu'il faut une
coopération très étroite
euro méditerranéenne avec les pays du
sud de l'europe et en particulier avec
l'espagne et l'italie nous en avons
d'ailleurs déjà parlé avec les deux
dirigeants de ces pays je crois que nous
devons réformer en profondeur les
politiques des de développement
aujourd'hui il ya trop d'argent gaspillé
de détournement de fonds par des régimes
corrompus je crois profondément au co
développement je suis allé à dakar j'ai
vu les familles dans ce village de
pêcheurs où les jeunes partent en
pirogue et se noie en mer j'ai vu les
mères de famille qui étaient là elles
n'ont pas envie que leur enfant se noie
en pleine mer pour rejoindre la france
elles ont envie d'emplois elles ont
envie de microcrédit elles ont besoin de
camions frigorifiques pour leurs
poissons elles ont besoin d'alimentation
pour leurs bêtes elles ont besoin de
projets de développement agricole
l'afrique par exemple pourrait très bien
utiliser l'énergie solaire comment se
fait-il que ces pays là ces pays
francophones et des modèles de
développement qui aujourd'hui les ruines
comment se fait-il que l'énergie solaire
ne soit pas encore utilisé comment se
fait-il que la france et que l'europe
n'ait pas déjà redéfini les politiques
des de développement je crois que nous
mettrons fin aux migrations de la misère
si nous réussissons à réduire les écarts
entre pays riches et pays pauvres où
jésus a grandi
et je veux simplement demain que pour
l'europe ce soit une mission prioritaire
mais je sors annick 1,5 c est ce qu on
pourrait terminer sur l'immigration
évoquer un sujet qui a été beaucoup
discuté aussi dans la campagne ces
problèmes du règlement des sans papiers
qui sont aujourd'hui en france de façon
que chacun puisse exprimer sa position
sur ce mois je prends l'engagement
devant les français si je suis président
de la république je ne ferai pas de
régularisation globale
la régularisation globale la france l'a
essayé à trois reprises en
1981 en 1981 11 en 1997 chaque fois avec
un gouvernement socialiste et chaque
fois nous l'avons payé cher puisque
c'est un signal envoyé à tous les
réseaux trafiquants du monde entier pour
envoyer des clandestins en espérant une
régularisation je dois dire que j'ai été
un peu stupéfait d'entendre madame royal
dire qu'elle était prête à donner des
papiers aux parents et aux grands
parents de tous les enfants scolarisés
en france comme l'inscription dans une
école et adroit cela veut dire que vous
crée alors une nouvelle filière
d'immigration je le dis comme je pense
la seule solution possible c'est le
règlement au cas par cas j'ai obtenus en
matière d'immigration des résultats
spectaculaires
il faut aller plus loin la france doit
rester un pays ouvert nous restait un
pays généreux doit rester un pays
accueillant aux réfugiés politiques et
notamment aux femmes je pense à ces
infirmières bulgares je pense aux
tchétchènes je pense à tous ceux qui
sont martyrisés dans le monde mais la
france ne peut pas accueillir toute la
misère du monde la france pour préserver
son pacte social la france qui est le
pays qui a les allocations sociales les
plus généreuses d'europe ne peut pas
accueillir tout le monde nous avons le
droit de choisir de qui est le bienvenu
sur notre territoire et de qui n'est pas
souhaitée ceux qui n'ont pas de papiers
seront reconduits dans leur pays
c'est un problème très difficile
et humainement très douloureux et je
crois que ces questions là doivent être
dégagés de tout enjeu politicien et ne
doivent pas être exploité à telle ou
telle fin oui par exemple comme on l'a
fait pour gmat de cachot je pense que
comme y aller quand un certain nombre de
people sont venus protester parce que
j'exécute est une décision de justice
vous avez raison faut pas faire de
polémique mais faut pas les faire des
deux côtés ni du mien n'est du vôtre je
continue je pense qu'elle est arrêté un
grand père devant une école et devant
son petit fils ce n'est pas exact c'est
parce que c'est quand même qu'ils aient
fait je pense cela si c'est exact pour
l'heure fait qu'ils soient de gens
perdent le fait qu'il soit grand père on
doit lui donner ses papiers ce n'est pas
ce que je viens de dire je répète je
pense qu'elle est arrêté un grand père
je n'ai pas ce qui c'est deux ans une
école et devant son petit fils ce n'est
pas acceptable dans la république
française par ailleurs je n'ai jamais
dit ce que vous venez de me prêter je
n'ai jamais demandé de régularisation
globale et générale de deux générations
j'ai dit que cela devait se faire au cas
par cas à vomir effet alors on est
d'accord donc oui sur le cas par cas on
n'est pas en sorte qu'il ne ferait pas
comme vous l'avez je vous remercie de ce
stade ci sauf qu'ils se sont dit mais je
crois que ces sujets sont difficiles et
je voulais dire et je ne jouera pas
jeudi soit champion d'exploiter ces
choses de façon politicienne sauf que
l'ours sauf que je n'irai pas
arrêtez-moi des grands pères devant les
écoles et que je ferai les choses
humainement c'est à dire que nos
attentes et gillet dans l'autre rue pour
le faire qu'est ce que vous a choqué que
c'était devant l'école où que la police
de la république faisant un contrôle
découvre quelqu'un qui n'a pas de
papiers alors s'il était dans une autre
rue il était normal que la police fasse
son travail c'est parce qu'il était 10e
et passionnément mais parce qu'il savait
parfaitement ne jouais pas sur la misère
des gens au saut je savais parfaitement
de quoi et que c'est suffisamment
douloureux et d'ailleurs quand on
regarde les cas individuellement je
savais très bien que chaque cas est un
problème et une misère donc c'est très
difficile mais ça n'a pas actuellement
c'est pour ça y est nous ferons du pape
cas par cas seulement ne font pas
politique d'immigration mais je doive
d'abord ne changera pas sinon il ne
plaisantait pas avec ces sujets ne fait
pas de dérision avec ces sujets ce n'est
pas correct humainement vis-à-vis de
dire que ça ne changera pas non ce n'est
pas ce que j'ai dit il exige en revanche
que je n'annoncerai pas comme vous
l'avez fait un chiffre à l'avance pour
ensuite examiné les dossiers au cas par
cas et pour voir comme par hasard que le
nombre de personnes qui ont des papiers
correspond aux chiffres que vous aviez
fixé en amont je crois qu'il faut que
les règles soient claires il y a des
droits et des devoirs comme vous l'avez
dit tout à l'heure c'est que sarkozy
l'est déjà
11h23 j'en connais deux largement retard
simplement comment
je termine ce quelque chose est ce que
je voudrais savoir vous êtes allé
récemment dans un foyer de femmes
battues et vous avez promis à toutes les
femmes battues étrangères d'avoir des
papiers est ce qu'aujourd'hui ces femmes
ont eu ces papiers et est ce que ça vaut
pour toutes les femmes battues sans
papiers en france deuxièmement vous avez
déclaré pendant la première question
vous avez déclaré pourquoi vous laissez
pas répondre j'étais dans une
association qui est absolument
remarquable qui s'appelle choeur de
femmes qui s'occupent de famille
guy du bout de la détresse il y en avait
12 dans la salle je connais très bien la
dirigeante de cette association avec qui
je travaille depuis très longtemps j'en
aurai pas parler si vous m'aviez pas
interrogé là-dessus j'ai confiance dans
cette femme et je sais que quand elle me
soumets des dossiers c'est des dossiers
qui ont été réfléchies et c'est des
situations dramatiques j'assume dante et
je tiendrai mes promesses est bien dans
tout ça ne veut pas dire parce que ces
choeurs de femmes parce que c'est un
sujet bien particulier parce que ce sont
des femmes qui sont poursuivies qui ont
été violées qui ont été battus et
j'imagine la france que j'imagine c'est
une france généreuse et accueillante
très bien dans toutes les femmes
victimes de violences pourront avoir
accès à des papiers en vacances en tout
cas vous allez mais en deux familles
uniquement de choeur de femmes donc vous
pensez en off un tuk à la responsabilité
de l'état c'est comme ça de choisir de
façon arbitré comme vous l'avez même au
cas par cas il faut des règles donc
aucun regret à toutes les peintures de
violence c'est ce que met en scène de
violence aborder un sujet que vous
n'avez
pour nous tous c'est sûr sur les
institutions faut-il passer de la 5ème à
la 6ème république d'une part et avec
quelle majorité voilà avec quelle
majorité alors si vous n'avez pas
répondu je crois débuts sur les
institutions si
ce sarkozy à deux minutes trente de
retard donc il faudrait qu'ils puissent
rattraper aussi ce retard afin que
l'égalité soit respectée non moi je
considère qu'il ne faut pas changer les
institutions de la république d'ailleurs
je n'ai jamais vu une réunion dans la
rue quelqu'un m'a arrêté en disant il
faut vite vite changer anti-jaune
république ceux qui promettent la 6ème
république si retour à la 4e on l'a vu
dans
la tragi-comédie du vrai faux débat
entre madame royal et monsieur bayrou la
logique de l'élection présidentielle
c'est le rapport d'un candidat d'une
candidate avec le peuple français les
partis politiques n'essaye pas de
récupérer sur le tapis vert par des
manoeuvres politiciennes qui n'ont pas
eu devant les électeurs la vème
république nous apporter la stabilité
à donner à chaque français le droit de
voter j'ajoute que c'est quand même
curieux de demander changement de
république au moment où la démocratie
française est de retour avec 85 % de
participation au premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle ce qui est un
signe de dynamisme de nos institutions
alors voilà qu'on à 85 % de français qui
ont voté entre madame royal et moi 21
millions de français qui nous ont
choisis en additionnant pour le deuxième
tour et on va dire ah bah ça fonctionne
pas on va changer et moi je suis opposé
à ce changement il ya quelques
changements que je veux faire j'ai parlé
des nominations je souhaite que le
présent un public puisse s'expliquer
devant le parlement je souhaite que le
parlement ait davantage de pouvoirs je
souhaite un véritable statut de
l'opposition notamment avec un président
sa commission des finances je souhaite
qu'on donne davantage de pouvoirs au
parlement pour contrôler le gouvernement
mais en grâce n'ajoutons pas la crise
institutionnelle l'instabilité
institutionnelle à toutes les crises ya
tout les instituts d'aidé ou werner
situe à lima de vendre et de la sorte et
vous associez vos concerts tournois sur
hiver c'est très simple j'ai un projet
politique que je n'ai pas changé entre
le 1er et le 2e tour roger élargi
naturellement je gouvernerai avec les
gens de l'ump mais dans la majorité nos
amis de l'udf ont toute leur place
d'ailleurs j'observe avec beaucoup de
plaisir que la quasi totalité des
parlementaires et des élus de l'udf
m'ont rejoint et je ne vois pas
d'ailleurs pourquoi il en serait
autrement alors que nous avons gouverné
ensemble et que madame royal disait la
veille du premier tour que bayrou c'est
pire que sarkozy pardon sic quand on
sait ce qu'elle pense de moi ça me met
pas au l'estiment pour monsieur bayrou
mais j'irai plus loin il ya également
des hommes et des femmes de gauche qui
croient à la gauche parce qu'il croit au
mouvement et aujourd'hui je veux
incarner le candidat du mouvement par
rapport à l'immobilisme pardon madame et
donc je ferai un gouvernement très
ouvert de rassemblement pourquoi parce
que le président de la république c'est
pas l'homme d'un parti c'est l'homme de
la nation ce prix zone amériques prend
la nation en charge il doit s'adresser à
tous les français il doit dire à tous
les français qu'ils comptent et que dans
la nouvelle majorité présidentielle
leur place si je pense qu'il faut
réformer en profondeur les institutions
je crois que la france a changé le monde
a changé et la politique doit changer je
crois qu'il ya une crise démocratique
majeur je crois que les français sont
fatigués de la confrontation bloc contre
bloc je crois qu'ils en ont assez aussi
d'avoir des institutions qui ne leur
ressemblent pas et je ferai donc une
réforme profonde des institutions une
nouvelle république qui s'appellera sans
doute la 6ème république le parlement en
débattra les français également je ne le
souhaite par un référendum oui bien sûr
je veux d'abord faire en sorte que la
démocratie parlementaire fonctionne bien
et donc le cumul des mandats sera
désormais interdit le parlement verra
ses droits a renforcé ses pouvoirs de
contrôle et il n'y aura plus une seule
loi votée si la loi précédente n'est pas
appliquée il ya aujourd'hui une loi sur
2 votée par le parlement qui n'a pas la
totalité de ses décrets d'application et
donc les français en ont assez de cette
agitation législative qui fait sans
doute plaisir aux ministres qui les
proposent mais qui sur le terrain n'a
pas d'efficacité et n'a pas d'impact
donc j'ai vécu ce décalage entre les
annonces en conseil des ministres le
temps du débat parlementaire l'absence
de décret d'application est donc moi je
veux un parlement qui fonctionne bien
qui va contrôler l'application des lois
le 49 3 sera supprimé pour que le débat
puisse se faire et l'opposition sera
respectée au parlement je veux un état
impartial et donc l'ensemble des
institutions qui dont la partialité
doivent être doit être garantie seront
désignés à la majorité des 3 5e de
l'assemblée nationale ce sera le cas
pour le conseil constitutionnel ce sera
le cas pour la haute autorité de
l'audiovisuel
il y aura aussi une modification de la
nomination des membres du conseil
supérieur de la magistrature car je veux
que ces institutions retrouve vraiment
leur impartialité et que l'état ne soit
pas aux mains d'un seule particule il y
aura ensuite une réforme de la
démocratie sociale je l'évoqué tout à
l'heure c'est le deuxième pilier il y
aura une nouvelle étape de la
décentralisation pour rendre l'état plus
efficace et plus rapide ayant il y aura
enfin un pilier sur la démocratie
participative comme c'est le cas dans
tous les pays modernes avec en
particulier un référendum d'initiative
populaire possible des jurys de citoyens
qui interviendront et qui permettront
ensuite à l'état d'avoir une juste
autorités et de ne pas revoir des textes
comme le cpe voté de force à l'assemblée
nationale avec le 49-3 pourtant par une
majorité qui a une large majorité qui
détient tous les pouvoirs et qui malgré
cela passe en force avec le 49-3 pour le
cpe et qui sous la pression de la rue
est obligé de retirer sa réforme je
pense que je pense qu'un état moderne et
efficace avec une présidente de la
république qui rend des comptes et je
viendrai rendre des comptes devant
l'assemblée nationale doit moderniser
ses institutions avec nos talons aussi
bien évidemment la réforme serait du
sénat et une part de propriété chacun
pour conclure tout à l'heure mais
monsieur sarkozy ça que j'ai déjà trois
minutes de retard donc s'ils voulaient
répondre
je ne sais pas si je veux respecter une
égalité norme ce n'est pas un problème
le jeu je vous vends des 3 millions bien
sûr je crois bien volontiers ces trois
minutes m madame royal moi je veux être
précis concrets et je ne juge pas ça aux
à la quantité et jeu ce tract à madame
royal bangs de ces trois minutes je lui
donne bien volontiers si vous le verrez
je fais ma conclusion juste avant qu'on
fasse cette conclusion
petite question personnelle comme un
petit pot au début
ça fait voilà maintenant plus de 2h 2h30
que vous débattez ensemble c'est la
première fois vous vous retrouvez
pendant cette campagne c'est la première
fois depuis 14 ans
nous avec arlette chabot avait tendance
à penser vous aviez des points communs
vous aviez vous étiez un peu rebelle
résidents votre propre camp résistants
combattants qu'est ce que vous pensez
l'un de l'autre
commençons par vous et que ça coûte et
moi ce n'est pas d'hier et madame royal
le sais bien que je respecte son talent
et sa compétence j'avais eu d'ailleurs
l'occasion de le dire ce qui m'a valu
quelques problèmes avec certaines des
amis et voyez vous je pense qu'on est
pas là où elle est par hasard
que le système républicain et fait telle
façon qu'il faut développer de grandes
qualités pour être le représentant une
candidats de sa propre formation j'ai du
respect pour le parcours qui était celui
de demain à mourir le moment on a des
différences d'appréciation de points de
vue mais je pense qu'on a donné durant
cette campagne franchement l'image d'une
démocratie apaisée en même temps
renouvelé d'ailleurs sinon il n'y aurait
pas eu autant de participations donc
c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui est pour
moi davantage une concurrente c'est me
le permet qu'une adversaire je n'ai pas
de jeunes et bien sûr aucun sentiment
personnel d'hostilité à l'endroit de mme
anna maria et vous votre jugement sur
colas sarkozy je m'abstiens de jugement
personnalisés parce que je crois que le
débat politique c'est d'abord un débat
d'idées et de ce point de vue vous êtes
un partenaire de ce débat démocratique
que nous avons actuellement donc je
crois que ce qui est important c'est le
choix de société que nous incarnons la
différence de valeur la façon dont nous
comptons exercer le pouvoir la vision
différente de l'avenir de la france et
moi je crois beaucoup au débat d'idées
et je pense que c'est ce que nous avons
eu ce soir et je souhaite que les
français puissent ainsi et choisir en
toute connaissance de cause
alors minutes conclusion de chacun que
vous avez commencé écoutez
si on doit résumer les choses qu'est ce
qui est important pour moi je les dis en
commençant je vous de finir par ça je
crois à l'action je crois qu'il est très
important de dire à nos compatriotes que
la fatalité n'existe pas le mot fatalité
ne fait pas partie de mon vocabulaire
ça fait trop longtemps que la politique
est impuissante et moi je souhaite que
la politique soit de retour la vraie
politique le débat on s'engage on fait
des promesses et on les tient je veux
agir je veux passionnément agir au
service de mon pays ou font la france
m'a tout donné il est venu le temps pour
moi c'est comme deux ans de tous lui
rendre je veux faire en france les
changements que d'autres ont fait dans
d'autres pays pour que la france reste
fidèle à son identité ayant aucune
raison qu'on n'ait pas le plein emploi
il n'y a aucune raison qu'on n'arrive
pas à maîtriser l'immigration souhaite
le président de la république qui rendra
la dignité aux victimes
je ne mettrai jamais sur le même plan
les victimes et les délinquants les
fraudeurs et les honnêtes gens les
truqueurs et la france qui travaille je
veux résoudre la crise morale française
la crise morale française elle porte un
nom c'est la crise du travail je veux
que les travailleurs ce beau mot de
travailleurs qu'on emploie pus soit
respectée soit considérée je veux porter
la question du pouvoir d'achat je veux
protéger les français face aux
délocalisations et puis je veux dire
pour terminer à tous ceux qui trouvent
que la vie trop dur à ceux qui ont mis à
genoux à terre à ceux qui ont du mal à
ceux qui s'en sortent pas que pour moi
président de la république s'il me font
confiance tous ont une utilité tous ont
le droit de travailler tous ont le droit
de vivre deux bouts dignement de fruits
de leur activité je ne crois pas
l'assistanat je ne crois pas au
nivellement je ne crois pas à
l'égalitarisme je crois au mérite à
l'effort récompense à la promotion
sociale et plus que tout au travail je
poserai d'ailleurs les les termes d'une
conférence sociale sur la qualité de vie
au travail et je veux dire mes chers
compatriotes c'est possible et tout ce
que j'ai dit je le ferai
je tiendrai scrupuleusement ma promesse
et ma parole je ne me suis pas engagée à
la légère dans cette campagne
présidentielle c'est un choix de vie
c'est un don de soi c'est une véritable
ascèse je me suis préparé pour ce rendez
vous et si les français me font
confiance je ne les décevrai pas je ne
les trahirait pas je ne mentirai pas
royal conclusion je suis là devant les
français d'abord je voudrais remercier
ceux qui ont voté pour moi dès le
premier tour ce qui m'ont rejoint ceux
qui me soutiennent je veux m'adresser
aussi à ceux qui hésitent encore je veux
leur dire de faire le choix de l'audace
de faire le choix de l'avenir je sais
que pour certains d'entre eux ce n'est
pas évident de se dire qu'une femme peut
incarner les plus hautes responsabilités
d'autres le font à l'échelle de la
planète il y à angela merkel et donc je
crois que c'est possible aussi on voit
comment cette femme est efficace et
concrète et opérationnelle
moi je veux être au service de la france
avec l'expérience qui est la mienne je
suis une mère de famille de quatre
enfants j'ai dû concilier cet engagement
politique et l'éducation de ma famille
je tiens des valeurs fondamentales je
pense que tout se tient et que des
familles qui fonctionneront en bien
l'école qui redeviendra au coeur du
pacte républicain la valeur travail qui
sera défendu parce que le travail sera
payé à sa juste valeur la lutte contre
toutes les formes d'insécurité de
violence et de précarité me permettront
de construire une france paisible où
l'on pourra réformer sans brutaliser ou
jamais je ne dresserait les français les
uns contre les autres les fonctionnaires
contre les autres ceux qui ont des
heures supplémentaires contre ceux qui
n'en n'ont pas ceux qui ont des
parachutes dorés et ceux qui sont
licenciés
je veux rassembler les énergies de ce
pays parce que ces énergies sont
nombreuses elles sont même exceptionnel
et je compte en particulier sur la
jeunesse et je veux dire aussi à nos
anciens qu'ils seront protégés et que je
ferai tout pour sauver la sécurité
sociale qui est aujourd'hui menacé et je
garantirai partout sur le territoire
l'accès à la santé et l'accès aux
services publics parce que je sais que
c'est une des conditions de l'efficacité
économique du pays je veux une france
créative je veux une france imaginative
et je veux construire avec vous cette
france présidente lui un autre tour de
vous remercier tous les deux d'avoir
animé ce débat dans tous les sens du
terme au nom donc arlette chabot de tf1
de france télévisions de toutes les
dizaines de chaînes de radio et de
télévision qui nous ont relayés ce soir
merci à tous pour votre fidélité
merci à notre réalisateur jérôme revon
et le rendez-vous et bien ce sera
dimanche 20h merci bonsoir bonsoir
[Musique]